All right,
here we go.
Boom. There we go. So, uh, first
of all, welcome. Thank you.
Thanks for doing this. Appreciate
it. Thanks for having me. John.
You are fucking documentary me that
that might've been one of the craziest
documentaries I've ever seen in my life.
The seven five,
if people haven't seen it. Um, dude,
what a fucking crazy life you lived. Jesus
Christ. Do you feel lucky to be alive?
You're embarrassed.
I'm embarrassed because you know,
I'm looking at people that's supposed
to be Spec to law enforcement and,
and it's almost, you know, almost slept,
almost glorifying some of the crazy shit
we did. I don't think it's glorifying.
I hope not. No, it's definitely
not. I don't think it is. It's,
I think it's an honest portrayal of
people going off the rails because they
didn't have the, I mean that you had
the ability to do so, you know, I mean,
that's what it was. You right. I mean,
it's just untamed and the ability to
get away with things that you could,
no one else could. Well, I think we're
seeing today with law enforcement,
with all the stuff that's going on with
all these kids getting shot and all
these, all this, these
videos that get taped of,
of police abuse.
We're seeing that for the longest time,
this stuff just wasn't filmed, that there
was a lot going on. We've all witnessed,
I'm sure you more than anybody,
but we've all witnessed some cops that
were out of control and that I think
that's just what happens when people
have power and you just kind of,
they get a little crazy. They, you know,
when you don't have anybody checking
that power and then on top of it and your
situation,
there was cocaine and there was crime
and there was all sorts of craziness.
I mean, I learned about your
documented from Nick Depalo.
He was on my buddy Ra should fear show
and he was raving about this documentary
and it wasn't even out yet.
It was your preorder it on iTunes.
I fucking hate that.
When you want to watch something
calling me like in the middle of the
night, where is this documentary?
I can't get it. I'm like, Oh, let me
call the people at all three media.
And you know, like they don't give a fuck,
you know, dentist, they're just like,
I was sleeping right now we're
on California time. I said, okay,
well they're not awake yet.
Ruinous. What did nick see? Like a
prescreening or something like that?
Did he see it in the movies?
Um, I don't know. I think, I
hate to say this on the air,
but I think he pirated it as
that's illegal because he had heard
about it and he couldn't get it.
And I was like kicking the ground saying,
you know,
who's promoting this God damn thing.
They, you know, it's about my life.
And people asking me a lot of
questions about it and I'm like,
why don't you go see the documentary
after like a week of trying to get it.
Then they throw your hands in the air
and they're like, we can't get it.
So a lot of frustration over
the way it was distributed,
but I wasn't involved in it.
So I walked in that pot,
I white knuckled my way through.
That whole thing was in touch.
Shut that off once I'm to tell you, you
and your audience how, I mean I'm a,
I'm a nut like, sorry,
I love adrenaline shit,
but I really couldn't
sit through most things.
And when the movie was
premiered the first time,
it was seen ever by myself as well.
I sat by the door thinking that
one I'm going to be bored or too,
I'm not gonna like the, the content in
the movie and just leave the theater.
And uh, and my family and some friends
were there, you know, not everybody,
but you know, select
people showed. And uh,
I sat by the door and like
in a minute and a half,
I just turned around in the
seat and didn't fucking move.
And it's hard for me to do.
I mean,
you'll see throughout this practice
conversation here, I'm all over the map,
but have you always been all
over the map? Um, uh, you know,
I think it's the Brooklyn, the
expressiveness with the body, you know,
we speak more with our body then
our mouth. For some reason I don't,
maybe short tongue down the line
and your English language, but, uh,
just the way we, I don't know, being a
cop, you always watch your back, you know,
so it's a lot of, uh, you know,
I don't know how to explain it.
It's just that's the way we speak.
Now, this is a very well done movie, but
excellent. The subject matter itself,
the actual story itself,
the facts involved in the story are
fucking completely insane. I mean, you,
you guys, um, you were
involved in so much craziness.
It was head of control, but here
you are. You're out on the street,
you're doing podcasts, you know,
you're doing press for the movie. Yeah.
You know, it's got to feel weird
for you to have gone through that.
It's different lives, you know, in the
way I see it. You know, I was a young,
young boy, young man, police officer,
convict inmate Parolee,
and at now I'm somebody else.
It's just weird how, you
know, Nikki Chameleon,
you'd just change with the environment
then that's how you adapt and overcome
anything is you should have to learn how
to live within the environment you're
in. And it seems like that's, that doesn't
seem the same. First of all, you know,
let's be real.
I was 23,
24 years old when most of these incidents
took place and then they carried on.
Uh, the, the more detailed,
the criminality took place later on
as I got closer to my 30 year number.
But you told him I'm 54 today.
So my perspective on everything I did
and my perspective on the world today is
way different than it was back then.
You know?
Yeah. Whenever I tried to watch a
documentary about people doing crazy shit,
I always imagined myself like, what
would I do if I was in that situation?
Like how, how would I have
reacted if I was a young man?
And I probably would have been right there
with you. Yeah. You know, it's, it's sad,
but
no, it's sad about that is it's people
given the opportunity to do wrong and they
can get away with it.
You have to ask yourself this question.
If I could take that 200,000 lodge right
now and just plain out question and
never have any negative
consequences happen to me now,
I'm not saying because she broke the
moral code of policing and all that shit.
I'm just saying just be a normal
human being. Woke up. Fine. 200 lodge.
No one's going to miss it.
It's not yours and you're never going
to have bed calm or anything happened to
you.
Would you take it?
It's a good question and you don't
need it until you're right there.
No one's eating no one even no one even
knows except for one person that it's
theirs and it depends on where you are
in your life. You're broke, you got kids,
you got a mortgage, yet you have
rent to pay, your car's broken down.
You've got no gas money.
If you're a 55 year old man and you
have a happy family and you have a good
career,
you make a phone call and probably do
something nice and you get on the news and
look at this Michael Dow, what a gentleman
gave away $200,000. He founded a bag.
Well, I didn't know what to do with this.
Not a good, my life is good, you know,
and in a house on the hill and you're
on blow. And I saw pop popping that.
Um,
and also it's interesting because you
are constantly around people that are
making insane amounts of money and they're
doing it by breaking the law. Yeah.
Let's, let's, let's focus a little bit
here. This is the 1980s crack epidemic.
Aish New York, right? So no action
I do was justified. Okay. Right.
I did wrong and I paid the fucking price.
I hope it'll pop.
Some people want me to FALive some
people want me dead, but you know what?
Fuck you too. Right? I'm here.
I'm out. I did my time. I served.
It's straight up. I walked the track
by myself for 12 fucking years.
Kiss my ass goodbye.
Okay,
so now I am here to talk about
the stories that made the story,
the seven five what it is.
I didn't bring this upon myself.
I mean the actions and all that.
Yes.
But somebody approached me from Hollywood
want to do a documentary about this
mission? Coolum Mollen Commission.
I told it's a piece of shit deal.
Do a story about the boys from the seven
five and I think you'll have a good
movie. So what was the original thing
they wanted to come to you about?
Well I was the main focus,
which is a thread throughout
the documentary is that
there was these hearings
called the Mollen Commission,
which if people know history,
they can go back to the KNAPP
commission when person, a person,
a surface hub protocols.
The guy that did time with Colombo family,
but so Serpico was a cop gets shot in the
face and the movie Serpico and in fact
he actually commented on
this, a documentary to
Tila, Russell, the director.
I got to, I don't know, it's two in
the morning. Cause these guys out here.
Don't know what fucking time.
It's two in the morning. My,
my text message goes off cause it's 10
30 at night, 11 o'clock at night to him.
I just got a phone call from Serpico
saying it's the best movies ever seen in
his fucking life. Wow. You know,
and I'm like fuck cervical,
cause I really don't like
second go to be honest with you.
Cause he said some nasty things
about me one until he was a rat. So,
but you know, he says, well Mike, he's
a but Americana, he's history, you know.
And so I got to give him his props.
I said fine,
but I really don't want to hear it.
He liked my movie so fuck him.
But he's not against them really.
But you know,
certain people would keep at a distance
and he's one of them that I would choose
to and I shake his hand and say,
you're a good guy. Serpico the,
he ratted out other corrupt
cops. Is that what it was? Yeah,
he did the right thing.
Yeah. No one liked the book.
I mean that's the way it is. Right.
What's that movie accurate that I'll,
but you know, movie. I can't look, I
wasn't there, so I have to tell him,
what is the word? It's a word
that it was accurate or, um,
the word is that the shooting was not
quite the way they said in the movie
itself, but he turned into
partners, you know, they what?
They wanted him to take the money and he
wouldn't take the money. And you know,
he was in transit, Jen about it
and someone shot him in the face.
Now that I've been in the building
half a dozen times at nine or precinct,
they actually shot another movie there
by a black. There's, I can't think.
What's interesting is your partner,
when you were,
your partner in this film turned you in,
but he was involved in a lot of it with
you and he never wound up doing any time.
Yeah. I mean, this story can go
many different directions here. Um,
Kenny was, let's consider a good cop.
You know, he was there to put the money.
What was his last name? Kenny
row. He was there for the money.
He would make college.
He'd lock of everybody's a husband,
like you would have a fight with your wife
in the ghetto and this was like daily,
daily thing, you know? And he would go
there and lock you up and take you out.
That was his gig. Yes, he
did that for years. That was,
that was his overtime money.
And I told him,
I don't really like to do those things.
And we got together and he had to like
a specialty. That was your specialty.
Domestic violence.
Ironically. But Anyway, oh,
tp term. There's this story
ironically. I see. Yeah,
I understand what you're saying. So there
was not something, you know, he says,
so, um, so he would arrest these guys
and how would he make money doing that?
Well, you'd, over time, every arrest
would lend you at least eight,
sometimes 16 hours of overtime to ping
upon what time you made the arrest. Oh.
Show.
He'd be able to make the arrest and go
to sleep for fucking 12 hours and make it
six, $700 on someone's misfortune. And
you know, they may have been legitimate.
You're rested and not saying they weren't.
Yeah.
So how would he make money off of going
to sleep? I don't understand that.
So when you are waiting to book a, uh,
a prisoner slash potential inmate, you,
uh, you have to wait for hours and
hours and hours so you can sleep on,
on newspaper racks, boxes in the
hallway. It was central booking.
Central booking was like
a mash unit. Really? So,
so your arrest the guy and then
you go take a nap somewhere.
Well that's how it was. Wow. Yeah. So
you would get paid to lock somebody up.
So that's why the city was against
arresting drug dealers. Okay.
This whole thing turns into
a whole conundrum here.
Like that word. Anyway, um,
the crack epidemic caused the city to
go broke in many ways because you'd have
police officers arresting people for minor
drug offenses that were, it was crime,
you know, and comps supposed
to arrest people for crime.
So what happened was of course so much
to process and arrest that they would
sort of discourage you. And by that
mean they wouldn't say don't do that.
That would never in policy, but you would
find yourself on a foot post somewhere.
Like I would get the post down in
Vandalia, uh, by the weeds. Well,
it was drag racing there
at night and that was it,
you know?
And so I would get like high allergies
from standing in the weeds if I made
arrests for drugs in railing.
Yeah.
So that's how they would discourage you
from making arrests and just to save
money. So, well,
would've bureaucracies exist for
profit and loss, but that's it.
They don't exist for the people.
We as police officers supposed
to serve the people, you know,
and then you'd come out of a
system that's not the it for them,
did it for themselves. So were you
there before the crack epidemic?
And I was there just before the
crack epidemic started. In fact,
we didn't know what it was. We used to
people just because we get drug calls,
you know, so you taught someone,
what the fuck is this from an it out,
we know what it was.
Wow.
And then one day one of my partners
brought it home and he came back with like
$500. And so that's what that shit was
last night. Or what is it? He goes,
it's cocaine. You know, you
gotta be fucking kidding me.
You've been throwing this out.
Wow.
Then that was a 84 or five slash five.
Yeah.
I remember hearing about it because I
was in high school at the time and people
started talking about crack.
Like you would hear it in the news crack
epidemic and then there's violence and
crime epic when you heard about it
because Len bias, that's right. Yeah.
In Boston at the time,
he was the basketball player that was
drafted by the Celtics and he never played
a day. Cause after he got drafted and
they gave him this big signing crown and
everything, he went out and
partied, did some crack,
had a bad heart on top
of it and killed himself.
So Ted Kennedy put these laws in place,
which would have to urban kids in federal
prison for fucking life sentences,
which now Obama's rightfully
in many cases, rightfully
undoing. And, um, you know,
that's a big political issue
that we, yes, it is. We get
into it, but, well, it was a,
it was the only thing I agree with him
on. Is that Ted Kennedy? Yeah, no. Oh,
Obama. Obama. Yeah. Well that's a big one
to the war on drugs is one of the most,
well, it's not, it's ridiculous.
They should just get rid of old rug
Lewis and let people go to rehabs. Yes.
Or they'd be no money in it. I agree.
I mean simple. Yeah, exactly. Well,
I mean they've known that since the
organized crime epidemic of the, the,
the prohibition, right? Shit. That's
what empowered, organized crime.
The ability to make shit tons of money.
That's what's going on
down in Mexico right now.
They're making money off the fact
that drugs are illegal in America.
When this was all going down for people
on the outside, like me, you know, I,
I had heard about it, but I didn't
know how much of it was real. You know,
you hear things about the news
and the news being, you know,
they blow things out of people are
showing to turn people into criminals.
It really fucking look at us.
I mean we were good guys.
Most of us were good guys from hardworking
families, cops, firemen, you know,
blue collar people, you know, sanitation
work is, um, bus drive is plumbers,
electricians and he became a cop.
You thought you were still in the same
genre of, of, of blue collar and you know,
you, you were the ones that the beast
was a quilt. We equated to Beirut.
It was like going to fucking Beirut
and you know, and, and supervisors,
which just happy that you with that and
like, and that we can hold a home today.
So, you know, so he took odd 10, 20
grand. No, no one really gave a fuck.
The problem was when people
start complaining and make noise,
then it brings attention. So when, when
you're there, before this is happening,
what,
how much different was the environment
that you were policing before crack and
after crack? It was, it was,
it, it was noticeable warm.
It was like a fucking tornado came in
and ripped the fucking community right
apart. Now, don't get me wrong, it
was, you know, urban ghetto that, that,
that to survive the 60s and the turmoil
and all that stuff, and you had your,
your, your racial breakdowns
within communities. But
I got there and I want to say 83 I
don't sell my fucking, I'm old now.
So I got there in 83 84 so it was there
about a year and a half and it was
getting crazy because coke was expensive.
Coke was 50,
50,000 a key. So it was tough for
the university community to have it,
but it was around.
And then when it dropped down to like 15,
20,000, 14,000 kilos, of course,
a crack and the volume of,
I guess whoever was bringing in,
you know,
there's many theories on who was helping
bring and I didn't back then. Um,
it just,
everybody can now get it.
And everybody now experience the,
you know,
the studio 54 high now
the kid in, in, in, in,
in the city was experienced for five
seconds. Mang goodbye. Oh, I loved it.
Now they're looking for the next hit
and it was just such as rock was.
It was blood on the streets everywhere.
It's fucking ridiculous. Wow.
Now when you go every day, every day,
every day, you just saw just gun shots,
stabbings and shootings every day. Wow.
It was, it was, it was exciting. Yeah,
I'm sure. And it's fucking great.
Well that seems like part of it to me.
Like when I was watching
this, I was like, Jesus,
it seems like in a way you're
kind of having some fun. Oh,
I have taught every day.
I didn't want to miss work.
I hated fucking three day swings and
the cops will listen to this date.
A lot of cops hate me,
but they sort of respect
me in a way because they
understand not respectful what
I did.
My honesty,
I hope that's what they take from this
because then you got a lot of cop fans
and shit like that and I respect you
in the [inaudible] guys, you know?
And most of them have really good guys,
but they get it.
It's the ones who get what I'm talking
about that will appreciate this
conversation. You and I haven't, well I
think if you're a cop in Orange County,
in Europe,
a police officer in Irvine,
you're dealing with the little
bull shit here and there.
You got to kind of know that is a big
fucking difference between that and east
New York in the 1980s during the year.
I hope not deal cause it got done and
he got to know what's the difference
between,
I mean it seems like it wasn't just you.
It seems like your entire precinct was
kind of full of shenanigans, but let's,
let's put it like this and this is a
take. Nothing away from the, at that time,
let's let's say 90% w w all legit guys
going to work with their lunch pail and
going home and live in
waiting for the next paycheck.
I used to get my paychecks because I was
making so much money. That's the truth.
And that got me in trouble by that
started this whole investigation on me.
It was because he forgot your paycheck.
Kept forgetting to pick them and
you pull up your corvette. Yeah.
Was the lieutenant spot. I pulled it
and that sort of pissed him off. Um,
you know, sometimes you wanna
make a point like, fuck you.
He's trying to take my girlfriend
away. Fuck you. Parking in your spot.
You're not getting her on the spot now.
That's hilarious.
Uh, so it was just, it seemed
like it was a lot of fun.
Like there was this one,
one case where you guys are talking about,
we kept circling the block. Let's not
get a better story. That, that was fun.
That was fun.
But I'm going to cheat sheet
with me because I got like
600 stories here and I'm
working with a guy named rob.
See you right now.
Him and I started to collaborate on,
we're going to do maybe the book again,
you know, we got to put, please do. Well,
this is a process. You know, how things,
you know, you've been probably
through this yourself personally.
We got some people in. Uh,
but, uh, I'm talking with,
with dealing with Sony a little bit
with trying to get this thing right.
I think rob Sia,
who's an ex New York City cop
who's done a couple of bestsellers,
he might be the right one to put the
whole thing together with me. I can speak,
he can write, he knows the color
in the middle. Right. You know,
we're a writer and uh, could, could make
it happen. Especially since he was a cop.
It was a cop and he's
got some credibility.
He does the Gotham comedy show in
Manhattan. I don't know. They run,
they run some live shows sometimes
live from golf on TV. Yeah, he does.
He does a lot of that stuff until
he's involved in that. So He's,
he's got some credibility as a common
cause he does he do stand up? No,
he's just, he's in the productions
of part of it and stuff like that.
But he's a writer a and he
wrote two bestsellers. Uh, so,
well I think we're going to have him talk
with, what's his name? Less sure. Less,
you're from the gun, unless
you, I think his name is,
he's got the academy award list.
Oh, okay. So, uh, we're gonna have,
we're gonna have a little discussion.
Him and I,
and about doing a month or
something about the seven,
five movies at Sony owns the rights.
Right.
We'll just try and make it
work right now, you know. Uh,
so there's a lot of discussion going on,
on making it come together properly.
So Sony owns the rights to do a dramatic
recreationary creation. The 75. Yeah.
Wow. Okay. Yeah. You
got to do a book though,
because I got to imagine there's just
no way they're going to jam that big to
tell you a funny story. So I'm, I'm on
patrol in Brooklyn and I'm working with,
um, I can't remember. It could have
been Kenny. I don't fucking know.
I don't care cause I'm just telling you
from my perspective and a down the block
comes, uh, this guy chicky
chicky is in the movie,
he's Pis and uh, he's in, he's in
the back of his trunk of his car.
The trunk is wide open in the back.
End's got to choke a poker machine
in the back of his car. Right.
The patrol car shut the joker
poker machine. Uh, people rambling.
Gambling machine. Yeah, you, you put
your money in and they don't pay out.
But they do pay out if you know the
right people behind the counter there and
you know,
so it's,
it's a gambling device that you can get
away with gambling or not. You know,
we hand out candy instead of the hand
out money it depending upon who the
patriarch. I see. Okay. So with
back in the 80s that was the game.
So we're driving down the block and he
comes to sergeant. He's driving this way.
I'm driving this weight.
I helped him load the machine into the,
into the back of a
patrol cop cause it's heavy.
It's about a thousand pounds,
this machine.
So we load this into the
back of his patrol car. Then
up pulls the Sargent. Yeah.
Sarge has no idea what's going on.
It's like, what's going on? Oh,
this guy pissed me with chicky. He did.
Should I say? And this guy pissed me off.
Who'd you know, the guy
behind the counter? You know,
he made me pay for solar as something.
Meanwhile,
he's got illegal joker poker machines
in his store. So chicky says,
that's it. These your machines.
He goes, yeah, the owner
of the patron of the store.
He goes, yeah, that's my machine.
So he says, okay, he takes the shit,
blows him in the back of his car.
He can take them home and empty them out
cause it's a $4,000 in quarters in the
machine. Right. So He's, the guy
made him buy a soda for a dollar.
Now he's going to take all the quarter
that a machine. So He'd come to sergeant.
So cars driving by, he's on probation,
cops going to probation, they pay us,
then he moves state patrolman, steady, uh,
sergeant gills from patrolman to sergeant.
And then he's on probationary period.
So he comes inside and on probation.
He's,
he's just four or five year veteran cop
would've with a joker poker machine in
the back of trunk of his car.
And he goes, what's going on?
He says,
Oh,
the guy pissed me off side and I'm not
letting him do this illegal gambling shit.
And then maybe there's everywhere.
Every fucking store has one, right?
So it's this, the 600 stores, this six,
that's 6,000 machines in the precinct.
But this one's got to go, you know, so, so
on and says, what are you doing? He says,
I'm taking, he goes, why
would the guy pissed me off?
He was rude and disrespectful and uh,
and it, this is illegal. It's a crime.
We got guys getting shot, murdered,
stab, selling crack on every corner.
He's taken this guy joker poker machine.
So that's how insignificant these things
normally are. So the, it's like chicken.
He may have disrespected you,
he may be pissed off,
but you gotta put it back please. It's
like, he's like, why? She goes, Oh,
I'm on probation. I don't need any
problems. So ps, we go, okay. So I,
besides no problem, bring it
back to chicky. Turns around
and looks at me. He goes,
all right. So as we're putting it back,
we drove back to the store. So I left,
went right from his, right from the stuff
from the store to chickies apartment.
Like you said you wanted to
apartments before anyway,
he had an apartment
local in the precincts.
We went to the apartment up the joker
poker machine offers his apartment.
I mean these are things we would do,
you know,
because just because you
could just because he could
cause you could what seems
like it was just,
there was a lot of excitement.
Like I'll do an all that like every
driving around the block store was my
favorite. Because you were driving around
the block for like an hour and a half.
Yeah. Well cause it, cause chicky
could, didn't get there in time.
He didn't have a car. Chicken had left
the job because of all the investigations.
It, you get that from the
documentary. So I needed someone,
Kenny wasn't available so I don't even
know if I was working with him yet.
You know, he'll say he probably was,
but whatever. Anyways, so he check,
he had his car in the shop being repaired.
So I'm like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
I need someone now with a car and a badge.
That's all I need. So I didn't want to
lose sight of the house in case you know,
for people who haven't seen
the documentary, what was
going on? What, what house?
There was a burglary call at house.
So we responded as patrol rifle and we
checked out the place and inside was two
young girls who uh,
were sitting there on the floor in this
home and it was a door knob broken off
and they said that they
were given permission by the
owner of the home to spend
the afternoon or day here in her home.
I'm aware, I had asked her, where did,
where did the owner happened
to be since you, you know,
you broke the door in order to get in.
Oh, she's in prison right now. I said, Oh,
and for what? And she goes, well,
I think for drugs. I said, okay,
thank you. So I turned left hard
and there's a box of fucking shoes,
piles about to shoes. I, if anyone
knows anything about the drug business,
they spend a lot of money on their
personal issues because what else are you
gonna spend money on?
You know,
you can't build a new house in the
ghetto here that she's just wasting your
money, but you could have a lot of
shoes. So I see all these boxes of shoes,
nice high heels, pumps, all
this stuff. So I said, okay,
it's a girl and he has spent a lot of
money on shoes and the furniture looked
pretty good for the location.
So I opened the closet and he has a
fucking duffel bag filled with cash.
I pick up actually that's really
not exactly what happened.
Some anti crime guy went in there,
picked up the big, he looks at me,
I look at him and go,
what are they going to do?
A voucher this come out and spend
all day in them. I leave it there.
He looks at me, he looks at me,
he goes out, he puts it down.
I put my hand in the bag and start
stuffing the money in my pockets.
But I had no room. I didn't have enough
room. I was wearing summer clothes.
I didn't have,
I went to uniform on with the jacket
where you can stuff everything. So anyway,
I said, this is not going to work.
It's too much money here. You can't,
you can't run out of a building with a
big field with money and have the cops
see you because they're gonna say
we had the bed go. Right, right.
So my enemy was the cops at this point.
So you know,
I found a way to circle a house for
an hour and a half and every possible
direction you could and it,
and then chickie finally pulled up with
another guy that was retired from the
jail.
They walked in with their Duke badges on
and the landlord lets them in and yeah,
up there. That's it.
Just, they just left that,
built that apartment right up there when
he went in and come out with the bag.
And about a minute later I pulled him
over, boop, boop. Pulled them over.
How are we doing? Real good. I
go, what are you going to use?
That's called Atlantic city. I go, great.
I go back to the cell phone, cell phone,
I go back to the payphone on the corner.
Back then we had the original call form.
You would drive the patrol car up on a
curb and just reach out to the fucking,
uh,
at t and t phone booths.
So you'd sit in a patrol car and dial
the precincts right out of the precinct.
It was a free call by the way. He didn't
have to pay for it. And uh, and uh,
it, boy, my wife, it needs to
be at home right now. You know,
one of the kids broke a toe or
whatever, you know, whatever excuse,
you can come up with it. Okay, no problem.
Come in and you can take less time.
It's called the lost time. So, uh,
I told the girl in the car I was working
with who was an IED plant by the way,
she was, she was internal affairs plants
sitting with me the whole time. I said,
okay. I says, you know, I kind of go home,
my wife just page who
had beepers back then.
My wife just page me the kid's
sick or something. And, uh,
so I went back to the precinct,
signed out,
went to Atlantic city in the
limousine and so cleaned the money.
The girl who was driving around with
you as you were going around for an hour
and a half was a plant. Yes, she
was internal affairs comp. I don't leave.
I ever told anybody that. But yeah,
she was an internal affairs comms.
So did she get suspicious that she asks
questions while you were driving around
in a circle? I told her, I said, just in
case someone comes back and breaks in the,
you don't want to see these people's
House get being sacked. The money,
she didn't know there was money in there
otherwise she would probably bounce you
to write. Right. We didn't
let her know that. Right.
But did you know she was a
plant or jazz so you knew? Yes.
Wow. Very good job of
hiding the plant. In fact,
I had a beer would have two days before.
It seems like all this
stuff that you were doing,
all these criminals that you
were dealing with, like the, the,
the heightened sort of environment that
you were in must've been very addictive
because it was just so much going on.
There was so much action.
It was,
listen,
when you're 28 years old and you drive
into work and you've got the nerves on
one side of your body freezing up on the
other side from the ahead to your arm's
going numb. Yeah. There was a lot
of shit going on. Why was it going?
I don't know if it was from
the coke or from the nerves,
just because she didn't know it was
gonna happen from one day to the next,
but you just couldn't get out of it.
The stress must have been insane.
It was insane. It was. I pull up on
the side of the road and say, okay,
if I die over here, it's okay. They'll
find me. I'm like, that's how crazy it.
So if you die from a heart
attack, I didn't know what, okay.
I didn't know what was going to be
driving to work. I'm just not sure.
So I just feel my body's starting to
go out, so I pull off to the right.
So it didn't hurt anybody. And I'm
thinking very conscientious here. Right.
That's weird. Wow. So there
was so much going. I mean,
how much coke were you doing?
Not that much. You know, I was just steady
bumper. I wouldn't do a lot, you know,
she's doing it all the time. Yeah. So
it wasn't like giant lines like that.
I'd be dead. Yeah. I don't know how
they did it. Well, I tried that once.
It almost killed me. When you
were testifying in that film, uh,
w that was one of the more intense parts
of that movie because you were just a
hundred percent open,
100% to your own fault.
Do you think you should have some things
that you should never fucking mentioned?
It's like what? Like with the girl
and the money under the fucking Bible.
Excuse me. God, you know,
I'm still scared of God.
I ask him for forgiveness every
day, you know? But, uh, you know,
that was the most horrific thing
I ever did. I think, you know,
the thousands of things I did, I took
some someone's $340, whatever it was.
I don't know. I don't know. Kiss
Kenny. He counts it better than me.
But was it just seemed like it
seemed almost for you at the time,
like when I was watching it,
like you were just so overwhelmed
with the pressure of everything,
that it was almost a relief
to get everything off your
back when they locked me
up when they hit. But if I tell you
how the investment down, it's insane.
But anyway,
when they finally put me in the car
and tell me I'm under under arrest,
it was like a, I can go to sleep.
Really. I can actually sleep.
And funny thing of it all was, you know,
and this is a little touching maybe,
but we're not, but I'll try
to be lighthearted. Yeah. I
call my wife when you county jail
and she goes to me, I'm like,
please don't take this the wrong way.
She says,
but I had the best night's sleep in my
life list cause I knew what you want and
you gotta be fucking,
yeah,
that's hilarious. I don't know.
It was, I knew where you were.
I knew where you where. I know she
slept like a baby. I had roaches
pulling in and my, he is, but yeah, it's
all good. How much of what was going on?
Did she know about? She only knew what
I was doing wrong for the most part.
And she knew there was drugs involved,
but she didn't never touched it.
Got Involved in it. You know, she
just begged me every day. Stop.
But it seems like you kind of can't.
It's hard.
Does anybody ever go corrupt
and then just go cold Turkey?
Like a heroin addict glitch
story? I tried. Did you?
I called internal affairs. Really?
Yeah, it was a cop. How old were you?
It was a cop. Like I was in the
middle of my hay day. I said,
I'm gonna have to stop
and turn over a new leaf.
My son was born and I had to become
a responsible father. I said,
and this is not going to work
out doing what I'm doing, right.
So I was in Coney island,
which is where I think the movie's
going to start if they do it the way I
suggest. Uh, I'm in Coney
island in front of the, uh,
Nathan's right by Nathan is
this a the bumper car station,
wherever he goes and
drives the bumper cars,
they bang into each other and
it was a rainy, rainy summer.
They might have been 30 good days and the
rest of the lousy for the whole summer.
And this was one of the days that it
wasn't. And uncles, this Mercedes Benz,
the guy in the car with a gold rope
chains, the whole drug package going on.
I just turned my head to my
partner and I said to him,
look at the fucking gold one,
this guy's neck now he's got boombox
going on those big wolf and everything,
convertible Mercedes, that's all I said.
All of a sudden they hear Yo, Yo, Yo, Yo,
Yo and I don't turn it for y'all,
y'all, y'all, y'all for nobody. And, uh,
but I hear the footsteps
feel the weight of it,
and I just glance back and I
see a shield in the guy's hand,
the big black dude monster. I go,
what's up? What do you want? You know,
you don't know where the fuck y'all
yet, but it's what I, Whoa, Whoa,
what's going on? He goes, you said, I
asked you can I park here? And you said,
can't you read? I said, where'd
that happen? That conversation,
all I did was turned him on. He was a
cop. Yeah. So he was undercover and then,
no, no. So he was a corrupt, comes
into Epcot. Wow. I didn't know this.
I didn't know him.
So you thought he was right?
I thought it was a drug dealer.
All I was doing was complimentary
about the comment and the book,
the package he had, you know,
the whole goal and the hopes,
the girls had the hoops with the dollar
signs. And it was, it was the package.
The girl had hoops with dollar
signs. That was the, you know,
those are the past. Any
girl, the dollar sign,
that's my kind of girl [inaudible] sleeve.
It's pretty clear where this is
going. Right, right. So anyway,
so he doesn't know you're a cop.
I'm in uniform. What? The island.
I was sent to Coney island detail cause
I was in trouble and east New York.
So giving you a hard time and he knows
you're a cop and I'm in uniform and he's
giving me a hard time, a very embarrassing
moment because you don't do that.
You don't pray,
you don't punch each other out like that.
Cause now you create a scene where
something has to be, you know, mediated.
So he's probably coked up at the
very, I'm not going to answer for him,
but he's whacked out. Let's put it that
something's going on. What's going on?
He's full of himself.
He's full of self important switch.
The fuck is he think he is
when he's talking to me,
talking about self importance.
Right. So anyway, he uh,
he makes us big scene and
I can't squelch the scene.
The sergeant comes and it's over
with. Okay. What about a week?
I could tell the story of different ways,
but the fact there's a couple of days,
couple of weeks later go by, I'm out
sick, which I should be home in my house,
but I'm out.
I just left the beach with my wife.
I'm driving home from the beach and I
see this call Paul because I'm on 11 by
the gross from the cleaners,
which is known for having a
crack spot above it anyway.
And it's his call and this is
fucking name on the license plate.
That's how we know that
the color stands out,
but it has his name on the license plate.
You can't fucking, you can't miss that.
And I asked my wife, I says,
what does he look like?
Get a good look at them cause I
didn't want to, I didn't want to stop,
turn around, make it obvious,
but I could see him, you know,
I've seen him a few times and I'll
get with them for 20 minutes. Anyway,
long story short, I go home,
I quilt internal affairs.
They brushed to my house,
joke from Bali,
the guy in the movie that says,
you get the hair on the back of his neck,
stood up.
He comes in my house with Lieutenant Ma.
They start grilling me about
my fucking life. I'm like,
I called up on a guy selling drugs. No
wonder why no one 12th to people. Anyway,
the tenant moss into Joe Trembowla
out of the house. And uh, I go,
is this about me?
It cause I just get a fucking lawyer
and I don't know what's going on.
I called you because some guy was selling
crack around the neighborhood. He goes,
well, how do you know he's selling
crap? I said, look, I don't know,
but he's in a crack spot and he's
a cop. So I'm telling you, right.
So I want to turn over a new leaf.
Start my new life. I got a new baby.
I think it gonna be good now. It'd
be a good cop. Four weeks later,
three weeks later, I'm getting calls
at midnight and whatnot. Midnights,
two in the morning.
I'm getting closed at three.
I work six to two shifts at Coney island,
three o'clock in the morning,
my phone rings, nothing, nothing,
nothing. This went on for about I,
if I say three weeks,
it could have been two,
whatever it went on for an
extended period of time.
Finally get the guy to talk one day
and I go, but what the fuck, man,
why don't you just come out
with this? He goes, he goes,
I'm banging your wife every day when she
gets off the train in Brentwood. I said,
really? That's nice. Yeah. When she comes
home from work, she don't work, man. Yeah.
Okay, so she's, so he
goes to train from work.
You picking her up and prep when you're
banging her? He goes, yeah. I said, okay,
so what else can you tell him? I says,
well, why don't you come to my house?
I tell him, and we just do this since
you seem to know where I am. He goes,
why don't I put a bullet in
your fucking head right now?
He tells me that I'm standing in front
of a plate glass window. So I'm like,
meanwhile my wife screaming
and they'll fuck what the fuck
you're fucking this whole thing.
So now I'm sucking sand out of the bottom
of my rug and trying to stay alive.
Oil into the back room with,
with my son and my wife was sleeping.
They're not in anymore. And
I'm like, I can't believe this.
This guy's fucking heat. He knows where
I live and he's got gotta be a cop.
I don't know that he,
until that moment I realized,
cause no one has my number and cops can
get each other's number by calling the
precinct.
I wanna get in touch with Joe and so
I want you to touch with so and so.
And we have a private numbers
in the Internet in a log.
It's a precinct that you can get my
number right if you need to speak to me.
It turns out that he was already arrested
and he was out on bail when he's doing
this to me. So it was the same
guy, single chain guy, same guy.
So here we are trying to turn over a new
leaf. You asked the question. I didn't,
I didn't pose it as you said.
So what you went cold Turkey like a heroin
junkie and tried to start from there
while I did and look what happened to me.
I they threatened to kill me.
They threatened to kill me. That's
the beginning of it. Then they go.
Then I leave the Coney island detail.
I'll go back to the seven five
and no one wants to work with me.
So if you'd go to the documentary here,
Mike's no good. Stay away from him. Nikes.
No good. He's this. They didn't want to
work on because they heard I was a rat.
What gave up a cop for corruption
night? He wears a wire. I never did.
By the way, Ken. He's good
with them. I never wore a wire.
I never Gayley gave up a
good cop or cop that did it.
Got was selling drugs on the fucking
long island trying to do the right thing.
Turn them in. I know they're looking at
me for drugs, but not no more. I'm no,
but when we're involved with drugs,
I gave up the game.
I wanted to be straight so you can't go
straight is what I'm trying to tell you.
Once you get labeled in
the police department,
you're done because no one would
work with me cause that was straight.
Well no one wanted to work with you
because they thought that you were
untrustworthy because you
were turning this cockpit.
Well that's what I'm telling you. Right.
But they would never admit to that.
They go every, anybody you talk to
the house, there's no, he was raw.
He was corrupt.
But the fact is they wouldn't work for
me because they were afraid I was going
to turn them in.
And if you hear in the documentary says,
well Kenny says we don't think you
turned me in for is having a beer.
You mentioned that Mike and I had to be
together and I could just walk away from
this partnership and they
put us in the farm together,
which I went to the farm three times,
so I'm pretty good. But the farm too,
what's the farm? The farm is where you'd
go when you go for Rehab. You know,
like if you need help, you're
like a intervention. Like
to do interventions today.
Right. Well they do. They did farms back
then. You went farms. He went to the farm.
Like an actual farm.
Yeah.
He would go to the farm like where cows
were cows and they had a fish pond.
They had hay fields and shit. And
what would you do there? Just relax.
You dry out. You know, there was a place
for mostly alcoholics, but you know,
and they called it the farm. It was
called the farm. Okay. Yeah. Cool.
Hops would go there too. You'd
be in rehabilitation. Okay.
But it was known as the farm,
right? Yeah, it's, well,
it's really renowned in the police
department. In Lingo. Okay. Yeah. So,
so I went to the farm three times in
like nine months. Wow. I needed to,
they were after me too. You know, they
were fucking hard on me and him up.
Two of my friends just went to prison.
Walter, who was in the phone, you,
they went to a prison for a robbery. They
committed. It was Walter the big guy.
Yeah. Wealth is the monster. Yeah.
Yeah. Always helps having a giant cart.
The fluff, the fluff is good. Was a
pretty sharp guy too. But you know,
he was young and dumb to, you know,
he, so he wound up going away,
did chicken and a short beard.
He did like two years and he came home.
Chicken went away for nine months and
then they came back and he needed work.
So I felt find them work different times,
you know? Right. He went to work for,
for, for Adam as one of my point men when
I was off, I put chicky on the, on the,
on the clock. So if I want it to
go home, do my, you know, go home.
They have to work.
I'd have chicky cover the next six or
eight hours a shift that they would be,
the Bodega would be open selling their
cocaine. Now that's where it gets crazy.
The boat day, that's where it gets, but
that was when you guys escalated. Yeah.
Well that's all we got really
little cocaine dealing. Yeah. Yeah.
Well what it was was w w the
handwriting was on the wall that,
cause the 77th suit went down for shaking
down local thugs and drug dealers. And,
uh, the rumor was that seven five was
going down. So we stopped doing that.
I went to Coney island, half the guys left
the fuck at the precinct to just quit,
quit the police department and
chicky one of them. And, um,
when I came back to the 75, no one
wanted to work with me. And, uh, in fact,
not one of my first days back, I hook
up with Walter, who's a rookie kid,
didn't know anything except that,
you know,
he liked to make arrests and get involved
and shit. And then I'm like, dude,
you don't know who I am.
I just don't mind.
I just want none of nothing
to do with this stuff. And um,
he's like, yeah, I'll, I'll make the
arrest that they look at him like, Hey,
you're going to really stop crime in here.
You can make an arrest for a fucking,
for a drug. Okay, good. But I want to do
with it cause I don't want the attention.
Meanwhile,
Joe Trembowla to guidance following,
he's across the street
watching us interact.
So time I call,
that's a long story.
I called for the sergeant to give us a
scratch so he can be done for the day.
Scratching me.
He's the sergeant comes by a note,
give you notification that you were on
what you're supposed to be. I'm asking,
exploding to give us a scratch just by
calling something over the air and not
asking for the scratch cause
that would be inappropriate.
But I been calling him a car license.
Blatant sergeant shows up.
It gives us a scratch with done
for the day. I get my private car,
go to the Bodega pickup for
Hamburgers and eight pack.
A little nip bud lights of,
no they weren't but the regular
bucks back then and the,
so I was following us the whole time.
He's watching the store list. Shit,
I'm over now.
I'm over in the other end of the precinct
because one of my favorite but they
get from, makes a nice burger. And,
uh, we came back to the spot eight,
eight this stuff through the shit out the
window because it was the ghetto in it.
It's what you do like an asshole
instead of respect in the community.
You're fucked the community. Cause
you're an idiot. You know, you're dumb.
You're dumb, young and
dumb. So I threw the six,
the 12 eight pack of
beer is out the window.
And so I didn't see this flying out the
fucking window. He goes and grabs it.
Cans. Now he's going to call me in and
investigate me for drinking on the,
on the job. But Walter stood up and said,
no, we didn't have nothing. He goes,
I got the fucking kids. He goes,
well, they weren't ours. Uh,
what the hell was mud early on?
So I gotta I gotta you gotta love them
so they could have lost his job because
he was on probation when you guys started
dealing with the guys who owned the
Bodega. That's when the
documentary gets most crazy. Right.
And that's when it seems like you
guys had escalated, did gone from
just taking a little money here and there.
And having some fun and
going to Atlantic city.
Now you are deep with deep
and serious drug dealer.
And that's why, you know why when I had
the meeting with Diaz I said, listen,
you're gonna have to just to talk to
what you got to pass money cause I don't
know where this is going to go, but I
know it's going deep. Right. You know,
so I kind of put a number, 24,000,
don't ask me why he didn't say 44,000.
I have no idea. I just,
I think I, in my mind,
I broke down like this three months
clear pay for each of us, you know,
right at the taxes at that time we
probably would've cleared, you know,
do the math, you know, 3000
a month, whatever it was at
that time. And I said, okay,
so let's have three of
four months of Clia pay.
So if we get jammed up
we can survive like that.
That's the number I came up in
correlation to something like that.
So it was in case you got jammed
up right away. Yeah. Okay. Um,
brilliant, brilliant thinking. Right?
Knowing that something was not
going to be good at that of this.
And where's that guy now?
He's in like the Dominican Republican.
I can get them on the phone if you
want. Really? Oh, I get them. All right.
And it was fucking hilarious. He's
one of the best, oh, shaking him.
Speaking to him. He asked me to
give you this. Oh really? Yeah.
I don't know if he likes her. I do
like cigars. What kind of this? Yeah,
this is the Adam d as king of Brooklyn
Cigar. What? He's got his own cigar.
Yeah. Uh, we just started in the
development process right now,
but if you check out the label,
you really can't see it well.
But as a picture of him with a unit brow,
he,
did you ever see the movie hit
with you at the university? Yeah,
I respect to commitment to a
unibrow. Yeah, he was. Yeah.
Yeah. I think he's good.
Yeah. No, no, they're, they're
uh, the tech tobacco letter
in the Dominican monkeys.
The delicious you smelling me and Marty
had one smoke. No, no, I wouldn't do that,
but I would that delicious. That's okay.
We can smoke and we've got a little,
if you wanted to we could. All right,
let's do it if you want it to. Yeah,
I've got a knife shaming. I don't, I don't
know her scissors. These are delicious,
by the way. I don't have
a clipper, but, so he,
but he's a fucking character.
That guy,
that fucking unit brow.
That's, that's a commitment.
I tell all pussies today.
You've going to tell you the story.
We're comfortable with blacks in
the ride to like a bitch, but pluck,
pluck, I shave. Do he really shaved
the middle right in the middle.
Otherwise I might have to
have more hair there than now.
I don't know what happened. I think
from doing this all the time. Yeah.
From frowning. Which is it just your
word off? Yeah. Well maybe from the Mat.
Maybe get that show that defense defense.
A funny story with Adam and I think most
people appreciate this. I hope they do.
Uh, I had him pay me 8,000
a week right now and um,
I don't see him for two weeks now I'm
getting fucking nervous. Right, right.
What do we got? Oh, Paris. Hey,
go and fuck happened to these two guys.
What are you doing?
Checking crazy when I'm out here.
So Adam d as in,
I haven't seen each other in two weeks.
I'm getting a little annoyed because
I want my money. I want it on time.
And part of the deal was whether
you're making money or not,
you're paying me because we've
already opened the door to,
I'm going to start living
the life. Right. And uh,
can, can you open it by?
I'm going to start living. I couldn't,
my, my neck is killing me. What's wrong?
I got, I got two vertebrae
out of banged up there.
Someone probably agree I to run away.
No, I hurt myself at work. Right? Yeah.
Just recently. So Adam did. So anyway,
I haven't seen this guy and he's,
and he owes me now two weeks. Right.
Okay. And if you learn anything about me,
I don't like to be old and I
don't like it. Oh, I like to pay.
I like to be paid on time and
I'm always early. So anyway,
um,
I,
I finally see him, uh, uh, I've seen him,
he's got the Red Porsche, I mean nine, 11,
Targa 22 years old,
right?
Yeah,
go ahead.
Nine 11 title, but blonde hair, blue eyed
Dominican, 22 years old, convertible air.
He goes down a new lots avenue.
We had new lots in Vermont,
that meat in this little
a triangle and uh,
so on Kenny's with me in the car at
the time for probably the first time he
wants.
But anyway,
he's pretty good.
I just love the fact that I'm smoking,
not do it cigar. Yeah, I guess
so. So I pull him over and uh, he goes,
he doesn't know who it is.
So Diaz is getting pulled over by
the police in east New York and,
and I'm just hook.
Right.
But he doesn't know that it's me because
you don't reckon I always use this blow.
Right. This tall guy and he's
sitting down low on the porch,
trout
license, registration, insurance, got,
he's fumbling around looking for a shit.
He probably doesn't have anything,
but anyway,
so
he's got a Dominican pants on is nice
loaf is, he's this sharp looking kid.
He was fair, always dressed to the nines.
He looked good and finally he goes,
I looked at him and go, Adam, it's me. He
goes, Mike, he jumps up out of the car.
What the fuck have you been like? I'm
annoyed. I'm annoyed, but I'm being nice.
What have you been? I
was in Yale. Yale. Yeah.
Don't jail. I go, wait, hold on.
Just the only thing I can coin in my
life that I know of. So I go, yeah,
you're in Yale. He goes, yeah. I go, how
long were you in Yale? He goes, three,
four days. You're up in the
l three or four days. I said,
who do you know when Connecticut,
I swear to Christ.
Who Do you know in Connecticut?
He goes, Connecticut. I go, yeah,
Yale is in Connecticut, the college.
He goes, no, no, no, not college.
I was in Yale, Rikers island.
He says that perfectly. I go,
you mean jail? Not Yell?
He goes, yes. Yeah,
like a son of a bitch. So I think
I coined this fucking term jail.
Not yet or yeah. Not Jail. Agreed.
This is 1987 88 how long have
you been hearing Otero? Yale.
Not Jail. Yeah, we have a
jail. Not Yale. No, I heard 34
seconds ago. So here's the thing. Yeah.
So here's this guy,
Shane.
I
wasn't it in Yale. I was in Yale.
I'm like, you mean jail? Not, yeah,
you just can't say jail. Say it. Yeah.
Well if he texts me all the time and
then he goes instead of going, ha ha ha.
He goes, Jay, Jay, Jay, Jay, Jay. Yeah.
They do that all the time. What
is that? He goes, ha ha ha.
That's so strange. Yeah. That's how you
know Spanish people and making fun of you.
Jay, Jay, Jay, Jay,
Jay, Jay, a. Okay. Yeah.
So anyway, so just, you know, you can't
make that up. You know we're, well, yeah,
I'm thinking he's in college,
right? Because he's a sharp kid.
Why didn't you automatically assume like
I did that he meant he meant? I said,
I'm not as sharp as you,
but you're around Spanish people.
All the cheese out in the fucking street.
He's out in the street driving a Porsche.
He was in jail.
But who the fuck let them go. The guy
sells kilos of mine. Second. Well,
how did he get out? I don't know. I
didn't want to ask too many questions.
I just wanted my money and you
want to hear or learn about me?
I don't ask a lot of questions cause if I,
if I don't like the answer,
I'm going to get really
fucking mad. Right, right,
right. Well I want the money.
But dealing with a guy like
that and dealing with an
organization like that, you,
you had to know that, okay,
now I've taken this giant step.
I'm involved with a serious murderer,
cocaine dealing.
Motherfucker like this is horrible.
Yeah, it's horrible. It's horrible.
You sell your soul and you know,
what's the, what's the safe I can,
other than this, I, I got a little
annoyed with them. Right. So I get,
I'm not living at home anymore. My life
is a disaster, a complete disaster.
It's like, well my wife
up, I says, listen,
things aren't going too good on you
want to, we want to get back together.
I want some stability in my life. Right.
So she goes to me and I'm okay from here.
Oh No. She goes, I'm okay from
here. And uh, so she goes, um,
I go,
listen,
I'm going to Dominican Republic and I'm
going with this woman I'm seeing at the
time who was a police officer,
sweetheart girl. Anyway. And uh,
I go, what'd you, what'd you come with
me instead? She goes, take all right.
Have a good time.
Can wife telling me,
wow.
Wow, what a good kid. That's
a good woman right there.
I ruined everything I touch
anyway, so I hope my son, you know,
sometimes like,
I think adversity makes some women better.
There's some women that like to dealing
with the, uh, no offense, asshole husband.
Sometimes it just makes him
a better person. They just,
they learn how to learn.
They learn a lot.
Yeah.
Cause they're sitting back observing
this whole disaster town place. You know,
cause they're trying to
stop you. Anyway. Listening.
Yeah.
So I go to Dominican Republic,
right and thanks and I'm on a,
I'm on the plane and this guy,
would it be um, well groomed.
He's making small talk with us being the
girl and he's got some moment with him.
I was like,
I'm on vacation.
I'm not going there to fucking
rob anybody or make any deals.
And going there to see my
Dominican drug kingpin and see,
see if we can get the money pipe
glowing again, but a little,
just this destroy it yet.
Now my income's cut way down to
only make them out to 3000 a week.
I was getting six,
7,000 a week between his payoffs and
all my other shakedowns going on. Yeah,
I was doing good now and get a little
tight, you know, I got fucking four homes.
I got a kid I want to put away for
his college. Sorry I never made that.
But anyways,
yeah.
So there's a lot of things like I plan
to you and he's fucking it up right now
cause he's hiding in Dominica.
Right. So I'm going to see him.
So I got off the plane and
they're speaking Dominican
to meet these people and I
could speak a little Spanish. Uh, so I
said you'll swipe police were bullies.
[inaudible] got anyone
taxi or [inaudible].
Uh,
and Casa de Campo,
I'm talking to a cop and uniform as
a sergeant stripes on, right, right.
The cab drivers stuck,
beating them up,
start beating the copy and the grabbing
and pushing and trying to knock them out
in a way because they want to take the
ride and I want it to this guy cause he's
thinking he's a cop.
He's to mediate for me,
get me the right price
because I know to take you,
it'll take advantage of the
green from America. Anyway,
I ended up ducking, paying,
pay in hand and fist for this
ride. But in the interim,
some guy steps over to me to guy that
was on the plane with me and says, Hey,
yeah, you're doing, what are
you guys doing? What are you
going and like? I'm like,
I'm like, what you hear on vacation
two and we're talking back and forth.
I'm going to see this buddy of
mine. Yeah, Diaz. He's done.
He's a bodega owner in new East, New
York. And the guy like, Oh really?
Where's this? Where's he
live? I go, I don't know,
someplace in a lower amount or
whatever. I said, turns out if the DEA,
they fucking followed me on the plane.
How would you,
how did you not automatically assume that?
Because as soon as you said,
I'm talking to this
sort of my guess,
that's what the problem is.
I'm looking at it.
20 2027 28 yeah.
Well,
well I'm 48 I was 28 I probably
would have told him everything.
So I'm on vacation and they
don't have a good time, you know,
and I'm just looking for like
a friendly face, you know,
and he speaks to a mannequin and don't
worry, I'll take care of you. He says,
I'll get you where you got to go. I
said, great. So [inaudible] guy says,
I'll get you where you want to know.
It's fucking DEA. Oh fuck. So anyway,
we ended up in call,
we get with this,
we get all the way to this girl
Cassidy camp. I took it back,
I think it took three different ways to
get there. Should we finally get there?
And they put us in his house
with four different couples.
What like was sharing a fucking house,
but somebody, okay, no one's there.
Who are these other people?
I don't know them. Okay.
I want to love as retreat for the weekend.
And they got me in a house like for people
that want to go camping and hang out
together and sweat something.
I don't know. So I look around,
I got this for the couples in this
fucking house. Like I'm sharing a kitchen,
I'm sharing this. I'm like,
I'm not here for this.
So they drive us back to a, I
said, no, get me out of here.
So now they drive us back to this
little retreat right by the beach,
getting there. Everything's
good. Have a nice time. And uh,
I'm calling Adam every night. I mean
your country, Bro. I fucking like.
Do you see how I'm here, Joe? I'm in La,
right? I live in Long Island. I'm here.
I don't fuck around. I'm
coming. I'm coming. Right? So
I tell Diaz I'm here. He goes,
his wife, we won't answer the phone.
His wife says he's playing basketball.
Now if you show it the, as in the
film, he's five foot three. I don't,
maybe he showed it in five
foot three but he, she cute.
He's five foot three and cute. So
I'm okay. That's 10 30 at night.
Prince is really good at
basketball. What's it uses? Charlie?
Charlie Murphy talked about it. What
are you guys playing? Basketball.
So I'm calling him every day and every
night. Now I'm a little annoyed. I mean,
your country, I'm here. Don't show
respect. Show up. Right, right.
Plus the fact that you will be fucking
like $14,000 right now I'm getting a
little nervous, maybe three
weeks, four weeks pay.
And I'm told about myself, you
know, so I'm a little annoyed,
but I'm spending $1,000 $1,500
come see you for a reason.
Actually 4,000 by the time I figured
the trip out, man. Fucking, anyway, so
he's playing basketball. It's midnight.
I call this fucking house now.
Mad midnight in brewing
in this fucking phone.
His wife answers the phone at midnight.
Mike, he's playing basketball. I said,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
It's midnight. He's five foot three.
How much basketball could he possibly be
playing? I mean, it's country. I said,
this is not to disrespectful.
Tell him I said that.
I don't know if you can have somebody
hit me. Kill me. I don't fucking know.
I'm pissed. I don't know at this
point. Who Cares? Right. Anyway,
we turned around and we leave. We get
nothing. We get ready to get on a plane.
About an hour before the plane.
I'm staying in a hotel and in a sense,
the center of Santa Domingo
and as a casino downstairs, um,
I left the fucking gamble eight Atlantic
city. Every time we hit a big load,
we hit Atlantic city. So I'm in the
casino. The Lights go out in the casino.
I got like 20 minutes. I put American
money and Dominican and money.
I used American, I hit him for like six
800 lodge right there like 10 minutes.
They want to stab me.
They don't want to let me leave.
They tried to hold me Pete there.
I got to catch a fucking plane.
Like I know it's a,
it's a 40 minute ride from where I am.
So I got to get going now they're
like your kitchen and I go, yeah,
let me go that.
They got flashlights on the table
cause the lights go out like every,
every hour or two to go
out for like 15 minutes.
The casino's not back then it did.
So he's standing with flashlights,
making sure everybody's money's not
getting stolen or robbed from him.
I can't shout and I leave to get
on a plane and come back home.
So I get home on the way home.
I get strip searched in the APP
now if you've gotta be kidding me,
coming from the Dominican Republic,
there's nothing but packages where
people with ropes and cardboard boxes.
I got walking like real luggage. You know
these people have stamps on the side.
Yeah. Yo won the fucking side of
their boxes coming in and right.
Women's have their thighs cut open so
they can stuff packages are fucking coke
in their thighs. Right. But I'm coming in
with a little bag and a little, no. My,
my little Guinea tee,
whatever fucking wearing and coming from
Dominica and I'm getting strip searched
in the airport. So I'm looking around them
and saying, this is fucking some setup.
Anyway, I, it's a set up right
now, Mike Gout is finally,
you're waking up, you know,
and I go, what's that fucking
Trump? I didn't know his name.
I thought it's a track bound. His
name is [inaudible] boldly. I goes,
that fucking track bomb. I'm, I know
it is. Anyway, get strip searched.
She gets cavity search. I choke up on the
plane. I broke up with her on the plane,
on the plane on the way back because
I was going to, my wife said, okay,
go have fun. Come back. We'll talk. Right.
So on the way back, you're like, yeah,
but you know, I'm going back. I'm
going home or at the wall. Right.
So, yeah, she's a, she's distraught
now. She's getting bent off.
I just fucked up and now these people
are fucking her. It was horrible.
I mean that's me laughing because you
know, life is, you know, the horrible,
you know well after the fact,
right. Exactly. So anyway,
so we get home and whatever
we do at lists, deeds and uh,
outside the fucking salt. I didn't want
to tell us zone was outside. Fucking it.
A license plate numbers down.
They'd flashlights on the,
on the inspection stickers for a cause.
The turtle affairs with outside marked
in the locations and the times and
everything else that,
that I was at the house.
I didn't want to tell him and spook.
Uh, so, uh, anyway, a week goes by,
two weeks go by. Whenever it was
finally a, I met Byron Sharp.
What are sound city with this whole
thing basically centers around and uh,
Adams there and I want to fucking, I
don't know for the bite him, kick him,
hug him or stab him. I'm fucking,
I want to kill him. Right?
Like what the fuck I was in your country.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
He goes, the DEA had your phones
while you were in Dominican Republic.
He said, they tapped you,
they volunteer. He said,
I was warned by the
Dominican beliefs department,
the state of fuck away from you.
Wow.
You think you would've
sent a pigeon or something?
Send me a message while
he probably couldn't,
probably probably couldn't trust anybody.
It's probably one of those situations
where what can you do if you're,
if you know that you're being tapped
and you know that they're watching,
it's probably best to just play
basketball. That's what he was doing,
which you got to do sometimes just
lay low and hope that he sees you.
That makes sense. Yeah. Well he's a smart
guy. Why did you avoid getting killed?
That's, that's what is most shocking
that you were involved with.
I mean, listen, you go into a ring,
you think he coming out, right? Yeah.
That's it.
So just do realize now,
like we're looking back on
it like Jesus fucking Christ.
Like I came really close.
Well,
the most serious of front that I faced
was that guy cello that you mentioned in
the documentary.
And why I say that it's not because
at any moment something could have,
could have gone wrong in
any deal, you know? Um,
cause at some point I began purchasing
the coke from these guys because they
couldn't constantly front you fucking
kilos cause they loved you and I can only
get by them,
provide
them protection cause I wasn't,
they took my guns and badger away.
Actually I should, I should've ended
it. Done. Let's not just keep it real.
I surrendered my gun and badge.
Why don't you surrender it?
Cause I was trying to get up to job on
a psycho disability, psycho disability,
you know, I mean it makes sense,
right? But they gave me my guns back.
This was what's ruinous. They gave
it to you back. They go, nope,
we did an investigation. We
decided you're gay. Okay.
And I'm reading the fucking papers.
You don't even know. This is surreal.
I'm reading this. It see a piece of
paper. I have you on this piece of paper.
There's a guy, he's about 90 years old.
This is no joke, not a bit, not here,
but there's a 90 year old guy.
He's the head shrink and the
whole new city police department.
He's got this piece,
this dossier in front of him.
He leaves it out and I'm in there
to get my gun and badge back
is 90 so he turns around and he's
got to go about 50 feet this way.
Open a locker with a lock on it. I take
my gun in my bag and give it back to me.
So I'm sort of like doing a nick twist
and curl and it says four or five
separate allegations for selling
narcotics and have a red corvette and this
guy's giving me back my gun and badge.
I'm like, this is fucking unbelievable.
It's the first time I have
a sore officially in writing
what they had me under
investigation,
well there's 19 different fucking listed
investigations of four specifically at
one period of time from like 86 87 88
specifically laid out week after week.
What they were looking for me for. I'm
like, and this is from a red corvette.
So I knew exactly what time that was.
I only had the red corvette for a
short period as well. So I'm like,
I can't believe they give me my shit
back. I mean, this is, this is now I know.
I'm scared.
I don't know.
Do, do you think that
they were giving you ship?
Actually you could keep doing what you're
doing. They catch you on more shit.
Was that the idea behind it?
They don't ever want to catch you.
Really. They don't ever want to catch
you. They want you to stop at that point.
It's saying,
I don't want to catch you because if
they catch you at Fox with the whole
department and then a black guy for
everybody, which is true when it's hot,
you know, listen, what I did was
not good. We know that. Right?
What you were just talking about
it right now. Do you know that, uh,
what it was it Tamir rice is that the
kids named the 12 year old kid that got
shot, they uh, they decided that
it was okay that there was no,
nothing wrong that didn't
investigation show.
There's nothing wrong with
the way the officer acted.
Got Out of his carbon and two seconds
shot this 12 year old kid who had a gun,
fake gun,
toy gun.
Joe. A lot of these things
that you mentioned, I don't
know all the facts on a,
I'm not here to bash what cops do cause
what they do as an impossible job, right.
The problem is that everybody
makes mistakes and when
you're a cop and you make
a mistake can cost somebody their life
and that's, that's the reality. You know,
and you know, if you ask me is it
other solutions and other alternatives,
I say absolutely. Uh,
you know, give a cop, uh,
the body cameras give them more body
cameras. Why not? I mean, you know,
everyone else is filming. You might
as well be the filming it. Yeah.
Problem was this story. Totally unrelated
story, but this story was on camera.
[inaudible] I, you know, I caught a
little glimpse of some stuff, Joe.
I try not to pass judgment
because I'm not the one there.
I've been in a hundreds. Listen, in East
New York, I pulled my gun out every day.
I probably pull my gun out 15 times
a day and I never shot anybody.
So you pulled your gun out
to Warren people. You pull
you to let them know that,
let them know that this
is serious and that, uh,
I need to know where your hands
are right now. Right now. Right.
Your hands on my threat.
Right.
And if I don't see your hands and you
don't comply with me with your hands,
then I may have to kill. You
may have to. I don't want to,
but I'm letting you know. It's
amazing. You never shot anybody. Yeah.
Clothes cut for cars.
I actually shot a cop ones really
undercover on the cover cheese.
It was beating up some kids,
some he had a gun on a kid and
I told him to drop his gun.
He wouldn't drop his gun.
I was with Kenny that time.
He could probably tell the story as
well because he remembers everything
perfectly. Um, but he talked to
that guy anymore. Kenny? Not really.
They're not, but we don't have a good
relationship, let's put it that way.
I would imagine that would be a strain
on the friendship when a guy puts your
way to 12 years.
It's not even that anymore.
It's more the way he's handled
things since then. He's just, listen,
I don't begrudge him for
what happened to his life.
He made decisions in his life based on
more than just his own freedom. Okay.
His wife's freedom was at stake
as well. Okay. Has Children's, uh,
being put into a foster home possibility
was there because you know, right.
I understand that I, dory was directly
involved in certain things. His wife,
you two together on a podcast would be
fucking epic. What we tried to audience,
we couldn't do it together.
Did you know we worked on all these,
we wouldn't sit in the same room.
I listen because I really don't want to
give him the credibility that he does
not deserve because he continually,
we have were at odds over certain things
and aspects of the story in certain
aspects of the story. And, uh, when I
confront him and he just tells me, well,
you're a liar. You know, what
do I have to lie about it?
What do I have to fucking
lie about? Right? I'm the
guy who did the fucking time.
I have nothing to lie about. If you'll
remember things differently than I,
that's fine, you know? But
the reality is, uh, you know,
I'm just going to touch on it briefly.
This kidnapping slash murder slash
whatever execution slave functioned at the
end. We weren't going to the
woman's house to do that. Okay?
You weren't going to the woman's
House to survey her house.
He insisted that we welcome
to the front door. I said,
what are you out of your fucking mind?
That's not even in the plan.
That doesn't make the tapes. That's
what I've been in the plant, Kenny.
Yeah. Well, I'm not driving all the way
here and not going up to the front door.
First of all,
that shouldn't even be a
discussion because we're not
going to have to the front
door. This other people involved in
this. They're going to go in and tell me,
get you on recording saying they
had to get rid of this woman.
He said to quit. You don't, here
is what he's saying for 20 minutes,
30 minutes saying they're going to
execute them. Like you don't look at me.
I'm like, who? Who's going to execute
it? The Colombians. He keeps saying,
right. First of all, where
are the Colombians? Second.
Well they're not here and third of all,
whatever we throw,
whatever I want to get past the
compensation. Right. Cause I've,
since he's fucking taping
it, quite sensitive to, to,
I've asked him numerous times,
Kenny, you wearing a wire? Come on.
Just tell me the truth.
So who this before he was wearing a wire,
you thought he was wearing a wire?
No, while he was wearing a watch.
So you knew when shit was going down. That
wasn't making sense. So I kept saying,
I'm be wearing a wire. No, no Mike, I've
been able to do that to you. I'm like,
I want to believe this guy. You
know, I want to believe him.
Should one of those things
like remembering those
old stupid TV shows where
you'd have to say you'd ask a cop,
are you a cop?
And then they would have to tell you.
Remember that what people fucking
believe that which is God damn hilarious.
You know if a cop, if you just ask him if
he's a cop, they got to tell you. Yeah,
right. Good luck. Fucking fantasy land
that you're living in luck with that one.
That's,
that's God damn.
Alexia cop is allowed to do a bump
if he has to stay alive. Well,
there are allowed in Hawaii to
fuck prostitutes. Well that's good.
I'm on a job there. Did
you hear that? That's true.
It's a recent thing.
They made a recent decision that police
officer's in a y or allowed to have sex
with prostitutes on the job as a
part of an ongoing investigation let,
because they can't get enough on
their own. I mean come on. Well,
because they have to find out
things and the yes, I understand.
Let's say fuck,
you got to fuck me and then we can talk.
We'll probably work intimacy.
Like I said, let's go there.
Your own private detective agency.
Well undercover women wind up fucking drug
dealers and stuff all the time. Right.
It's a dark secret, isn't
it? Release. It isn't moving.
Well they could've gotten me pretty
easily that way then couldn't they?
Why didn't they do that? Yeah,
why don't we send Kenny and
good and I
just that,
that build the neighborhood I would have
done just sending one of those little,
you know, dime packages and we'll
the tape recorders back then though.
We're fucking giant monsters
VCR looking things man.
And I didn't check them because
I, it was too, I was too proud.
Like you wouldn't do that to
me. And my brother says to
me, Mike, did you toss him?
I go, yeah, I didn't. Wow.
And thank God I didn't that
day cause I well thank God.
I mean what's the difference? I see I
was going to do with my time either way,
but what if he had killed him or something
or what if you would've been messy.
Thank God. None of us think I didn't find
out. Yeah, anything could have happened.
I don't know.
It would have been an assault and
violence and brought another level to
something else.
And you had threatened to witness how
the fuck that I know he was a witness
still a minute ago. Right? Exactly.
That's the sneaky thing about it.
Now you went away for 12 years.
I'm sentenced to 14 years.
I took a plea agreement that was 10
to life. Okay. That's the [inaudible].
That was the play.
And so how does it fall like they offered
me 24 to 30 that was my first offer.
I call my lawyer. What the fuck
did I kill somebody? He goes, well,
I'm not just the way the federal
government, as I said, that's nice.
So 12 to 12 to 24
to 30 was my first offer. Now,
what pisses me off is here's a guy,
he doesn't realize what he's dead just
dead to a guy who he was eating my house,
Debbie,
you know,
a couple of weeks ago and now he doesn't
realize that instead of just doing our
time together, like
just take the w, let me,
let me backtrack a little bit and we'll
try to remember that where we were. Okay.
When we were out on bail,
Kenny handsome options as I did to either
cooperate with the government and give
everything up and just go on and do
your memory a little bit in your life,
whatever it might amount
to have been too little.
It might've been more so I
get off on a shrimp boat trip,
a job in Nicaragua to run shrimp shrimp.
They often,
who the fuck is offering your shirt,
the owner of the story of hotel,
not story of manner. In in a
story queens, he's got a k,
a catering hall with a bunch of
weddings and most weddings they loved,
they had shrimp and every wedding, here's
11 rooms in the, in the catering wall.
So he's got 11 people, sometimes twice
a day filtering shrimps or was business.
So he says like, Mike, you're going
away for a long period of time. He said,
so I got an option for you. I need
a shrimp boat, Captain Nicaragua,
you want to go? I went, oh man.
So you know, I'm looking for any,
anything to grab onto at that point in
my life. And I go home and I'm like,
I give Kenny a call. I said, Kenny,
listen, I want to talk to you Mike.
I don't know if we should talk as Ken,
let's meet and talk.
So we have a conversation and
he says, Mike, I got a pension.
I've got a wife and a kid. He says, I'm
not giving that shit up. And you go, shit,
if I ever have to, if I have to do a
little bit, I have to do it fine. I says,
but I'm not giving it all to a shrimp
boat fishing in Nicaragua. I said, okay.
Done story done. Case closed,
done. Never happened. Okay.
Three, four days later, maybe less,
two days later, the phone rings. Mike,
I'm interested in gold fishing.
Nobody talking about fishing.
So he comes to see me. He says, ah,
now I see the fucking DEA over here.
I see something over here. I see
everybody. I'm, I'm being followed. I go,
what are you talking about?
He goes, I want to go fishing.
Remember the fishing trip
you're talking about last week?
I know what fishing trip. Fucking, you
know the Marlin fishing trip. What?
Fishing trip. He won't say the
word shrimp boat in Nicaragua.
Why? Wow. It's has to come from me.
Why does it have to come from me?
Because it, if you're working
for the government at this point,
you can't be the one that interacts the
person. It has to come out of my mouth.
So him saying, let's go fishing
trip. Let's go fishing. Yeah. Right.
So he wants you to see, cause he wants
you to say, I'm going to skip the country.
Correct.
He wants me to say,
you mean like I do the shrimp
boat job in Nicaragua, right? Yes.
She jumps up out of his fucking chair.
I'm like looking at what the fuck are
you so excited about and now I know
something's wrong. So
yeah, he's ridiculous.
So now I go, okay, something's not right.
And I started finding the fucking set
up everywhere around me and he's opening
the window in his car, his
perfectly quaffed. I said, Kenny,
what do you open the window for?
The fucking air conditioner is on.
It's 95 degrees out. You here's
gonna get missed. Oh No, no. Anyway,
he disputes. He disputes that. And why
would you dispute that? Anyway, so,
so now
think of what just happened.
He's now come back to me and says he wants
to go on the shrimp boat trip, right?
He goes home, I go home. I
said, listen, it's a good idea.
We need a half a million plus cause
I can't leave. My family broke.
Only houses are a foot and bail.
Two days go by and some Colombian
close me up and says, I got,
I need a half a million dollars.
It is a,
I need a half a million dollars recovered
and 10 kilos from this woman's house
in Jamaica. [inaudible] a claim number.
Just what I need, exactly what I need it.
Right. So, uh, suspicious. Yeah,
I'm a little suspicious,
but I can't believe God is
good. I'm saying he's great.
Look what he's doing. Something really
believed it. They played it off well. So,
and I'm looking for anything.
I don't know. I'm desperate.
Are you doing coconut?
No. No, no. Six weeks
clean while I was in jail.
So I was out on bail and no
one would sell anything to me.
I tried to pick up a package to my
own dealer, wouldn't sell it to me.
So that's when times are tough.
And the road on Coke dealer, my own
mine.
I'm not going to go to Yale.
I'm not going to yell.
So I ended up in the discussion with him
and a distinct presents itself and um,
he's all over it now. Yeah. I want
to go home like [inaudible] Kenny,
you didn't want to go before he says,
yeah, but now I want to go like,
he's like fucking screaming it. I'm like,
okay. You know, it sounds a little odd.
Do you remember why or no? Okay.
Just checking. Just checking.
Anyway,
so on and on and on we went and eventually
the sting was sad and this thing
turned into what it turned into. And
uh, you know, it is what it is. Well,
you dispute it in the film.
You say that you, yeah,
but I dispute the premise of the beginning
of the whole process. What the woman,
there's a controversy back and forth.
I never saw her, never met her,
never intended to touch
it myself personally.
Ever now how she was gonna get in
my car and gagged and whatever.
I don't fucking know.
Okay.
But the fact is that we were
supposed to do anything to her.
So for people listening to this that
haven't seen the documentary there was,
it was sort of like a last thing that
you guys could do to make a shit load of
money and it involved kidnapping a
woman who would eventually be murdered.
Well, this is in the film,
right? It's horrible. Yeah,
but the only his offense,
she was nothing that I never had
anything to do with the eventuals.
I never knew them. He knew
right, and they spoke Spanish.
I don't fuck with Getty know what
they was saying. Right. I don't know.
Maybe the government translated
for him, but what part, if any,
were you playing in or anticipate it's
going to take the money from a woman's
house? Come on. You could
do that in your sleep.
Take the money from a woman's house
and the drugs and go home. Give,
split it up with the,
with the Colombians and
God somehow along the way,
whether it be the government fishing,
Kenny fishing, someone pushing.
This woman was going to go
from being money that wasn't
hers. It was a drug deal.
Money that was killed. Her husband
was Dominican drug dealer who was,
who was killed by whom? I, I
can't answer that question,
but the fact is that he had a half a
million in cash and that home according to
the set up people and 10 kilos and we
can take it off and split it down the
middle and you'll have your money.
You can leave the country. I mean,
very convenient. Very. Yeah,
very nice. All I was like,
wow. What a crazy scenario though. So,
and that trope in front of shaking down
street drug dealers for a couple of
hundred a day to a, you
know, but see that's us.
That's like an attempted murder.
That's a whole conspiracy trying to get
me a new charge. No, no, no, I'm not.
But I'm saying like they obviously
couldn't pin that on you,
otherwise you would've went away
for a lot longer than 12 years.
So you answered that. You
answered the question. So,
but it seems like that was something
they were trying to concoct to make
everything a lot more
severe. Correct. Okay.
Now when you go where you went,
but think about how many years
you were involved in actual crime.
How many years do you think you were
involved as a cop committing crime? Well,
every time you put the uniform on
and you don't do the right thing,
you'd pretty much be committed a
crime. Right. And you have gone yet.
So how many years was that about? I'd
say a solid five. A solid five years.
So not that bad to go
away for 12 for a song.
You want to minimize my sentence
now? I mean every nasal,
no fucking day. I'm sure.
But I was going to bring that up too.
But what is it like when you go in there?
I mean first of all, you're a cop. They
know you're a cop. Everywhere I went,
they know what is,
that was the first person they do on
the compounded when I hit the compound.
And what is that?
It's like having 1800 men times too,
because they each got to wise,
most of them not, not all.
So you have 3,600 eyes on you. Never
mind the 600 staff in there watching you.
24 seven watch new threatening you.
You know,
you I both someone that could be a threat,
right? Even if you're in a fight game,
ice can mean either compliance,
you know, or fuck you.
And then then it's up to you.
How do you want to handle this date?
Did they think of you as almost one of
them because you were also involved in
crime and there was a
strange relationship.
Many of them wish that they
were me because they would
love to have that power.
I mean, right? Dozens if not hundreds of
said, man, I wish I was a fucking cop.
All right.
I think it really
well if you see in the film it
felt like he would, it just,
you could do anything you wanted.
It was horrible.
But that's what was my point
about having that kind of power.
But in prison you have none,
right? You're the least one.
They want you and the child analysis,
you know,
that's so is that how they lump you in
the right in the same category? Wow.
So basically when they say a the yard by
myself for 12, other than Mickey Monday,
who came up to me and said hello
to me. It was Mickey Monday. I
use that blonde hair guy from the
cocaine cowboys. You ever seen it?
Fuck yeah. Yeah. He's my buddy.
That's my friend Billy carbons
documentary, both of them.
Cocaine cowboys one and two.
That guys, your buddy? Yeah,
he went to jail with him.
I got a picture on the two of you together
was fucking great stories last week
and my ass crimes in Miami
and his favorite book and
a greasy spoon spot down.
Oh, he's out to, yeah. Beautiful.
Yeah. I was sitting there with
this guy, John Cod Dillo, uh,
who does a radio show on
Iheart radio down there, uh,
at of Fort Lauderdale a him and he and I,
he's a retired cop and he's a
great host on a show. And uh,
but talking about maybe doing something
together too as well, and the good cop,
bad cop show, that sounds like a
great idea, but you fucking piss all.
If you don't have a podcast, there's a
fucking crime being committed right now.
You should ask fucking easiest shit.
Jamie will tell you it's easier.
No, Gigi, he's sweating over there.
This is a way more complex
setup than anybody really needs.
I mean we only do it this way because
it's kind of fun to have video of it.
Live streaming, right? Yeah. We're live
right now. Yeah. How's my hair look great.
It's easy.
I wish I'd done this when I was 20 but
the point is like all you need is a
little MP record.
If we had a little recorder that's like
the size of a cell phone like this,
like I can each of the size of Kenyon.
Well No,
if he wishes yet something
this small back then, but uh,
I've done a few of them
just with my iPhone.
We just set it down on a table and the
microphones and these things are really
good. Yeah, you could do
it and then you upload it.
It doesn't mean it's fucking easy shit,
but I need someone like you to feed off
of. I'm not the ghetto ghetto. Like,
you just find somebody, you
just fine. I'm telling you,
one of the guys that I shook
down, you could do that. He's
funny story. I'm at, I'm at the, uh,
one of the premiers and I did
a lot of a great idea actually.
I am had a premiere and I see these guys
come walking up and they looked fucking,
they look a little
haggard, you know, and uh,
they looking at me with that
like cheapest, like look
and like, you know, I'm,
I'm like semi star the thing.
So I got to look all proper and
everything and looking, you know,
will ever date that.
And up comes these guys,
it looked like they from
the street, you know? Right.
So they got their hats on sideways.
Half their teeth are missing and the guy
sticks his hand out and he goes, Mike,
I go, yeah. He goes, I used to
hang out on picket and fucking,
uh, picking and um, [inaudible] not north,
cause no one does it meet it, but picking
and pressing and picking and chestnut.
And I'm like, okay. He goes,
yeah, you used to shake me
down. I'm like, Oh really?
He goes,
but we both made it like it was like
almost a fucking initial bond that you
could, you couldn't imagine like
I did my bed whenever he did.
You know,
30 fucking years later he's shaking my
hand like that at a movie premiere thing.
It was just saying, he was like, well,
the pouty, I don't know if that's like,
that makes sense. Wow. Go
of, you'll live through it.
We look at us and like only like 10
people live through it now.
Right.
Those three of those three and
me and a couple other people.
So in a sense where you both
survivors in a sense, no respect.
There was respect. It was nice to see.
That's bizarre. Right? And tell you,
a couple of cop came up to me,
they really didn't like it,
but they didn't like that. But they
came up and hugged me and said, hey man,
you made it, you know, go on with
your life, but you really, to me, you,
I'd have to be honest with you. You
know, you're still a company, you're hot.
You know, they were fighting. You were
a fighter in your heart, you know,
you know that, you know, it's respect.
That's a strained relationship
between you and the other cop.
But you give up your whole community.
Yeah.
You know when you fuck you fuck up
like I did, you gave it, you know,
and my whole family is involved in it
and you know what the police department,
fire department to your destroyed your
relationship with that whole community
and that's how you grew up. So I
basically destroyed every fabric of my,
of Hawaii. I am, you know,
but then again they have to watch that
documentary be fucking entertained.
They loved it. I taught people come to
me, you don't listen. It was back then.
So now they know and they know who I am
as a human being and really mean good.
I don't always do good. But I
do mean well. Right. Well like,
like I said,
if I was 23 years old and I was living
when you were living and doing that job,
I probably would have been right
there with you. I probably would have,
yo Yo one in a thousand of said the same
exact words. So this is some comfort.
Maybe it is, there's some comfort.
I, you know, there's this, um,
I used to have this different look about
people I should say. Well, you know,
you're responsible for your own actions,
which in a sense you absolutely are.
But there's also this concept that all
of your own actions and whoever you are
in a lot of ways are
determined by your environment,
by how you grew up,
by what situation you find yourself in,
by the circumstances you find yourself
in that situation. Yeah. And there's,
there's a lot going on.
And then there's the fun.
There was a lot that's a fucking
problem. Say I have to say, you know, I,
but I was watching that documentary.
I was like,
this guy looks like he's
having a great fucking time.
I don't know if that's a good thing.
It's not a good thing.
It's not a good thing what I
did. But here's the thing, right?
One of the things you alluded to,
so like who's bringing the
fucking drugs into that community?
You know who's bringing
the drugs into the country,
and I hate to go all
crazy conspiracy theory,
but the reality is there
were a bunch of rogue CIA,
CIA agents.
We're bringing it in bunch of rogue Agios,
Olly norths crew fucking
demeanor airport at a,
my mom can show dark listens
family that was involved.
I was in jail with his cousin. Yeah.
What was the guy that got killed?
The bearings seals.
Barry Seal's,
who was the pilot because
all these photographs of
him with all these Colombian
drug lords and and this guy,
he went,
he was murdered on his way to testify.
He had George buses phone number in
his fucking pocket when he was killed.
This is, this is, there's a lot of
fucking shit going on with this.
There's so much money involved in
drugs. That's why I don't I, I'm for
total legalization and decriminalization
of all narcotics. Everything.
Because you make criminal how the
people that generally not criminals.
Yes. It was just a lot of money in it.
I mean, yeah. The guy goes to a school,
becomes a stockbroker.
He finds out that the bill money isn't
being criminal criminal instead of making
his 60 70 or a hundred thousand
and you must make 66 million.
So he has to be a criminal. So, and
that, that's choice you made though.
He made that choice.
But being exposed to the
opportunity people find out
who they really can become.
Yes. Or we, we, you know,
I like to say you're not what you've done.
It's what you've become afterwards though.
Like someone hurt somebody,
you know,
in a moment of rage or something
or inadvertently does something.
Or will they go out of their way to
do something because for whatever the
driving reasons are. So they're forever
defined by that act. Yes. But that,
that's not necessarily who someone is.
People love to forever define people
by that act because they, they,
they in some way are very
happy. It's not them. Right.
And so they want to say you pieces,
you're a piece of shit forever. Forever.
But how many people did what I did got
away with it and throwing fucking stones
at me a lot. Okay. I'm sure.
Let's go back into the histories
in the list from between,
let's go a 85 to 95 every single,
call it ghetto precinct cause that's
what it's called in the police world.
Every single ghetto precinct had a scandal
very similar to mine except maybe not
to the,
the depth like you had initially said
when I really got into the paying straight
out dealing with the guys, let's
be honest, you're an all star.
You were an all star in the
world of corruption. That's
what it's like. It's like,
you know, there's a pretty shot to take
it to the next level. It's quite, I mean,
not everybody can be Ronda Rousey,
you know what I'm saying? You know,
not got everybody with Joe Jones,
he's had her last guy on TV
to the next level and you,
you took it to the next
level in the world.
I must say my mother and my
children are quite proud of that.
But you know what I'm saying? I mean,
whenever you have any sort of an act,
whether it's a guy who's,
uh, a marijuana dealer,
a guy who's a fucking bow hunter,
you're going to have people that
just take it to the ultimate,
they take it to the furthest extreme and
that's what you did as a corrupt cop.
I just found ways to continue to get it.
When you say better,
the guy like Serpico,
like you think he's a piece of shit
or you think he's a man? I mean,
I have nothing personal against, no. You
understand what I'm hang out with him, uh,
you know, for any period of time. But
you kind of dabbled in that when you,
when I turned it on and the guy
with the gunshot, right, right.
And quickly went back to being a criminal,
but it paid better until, uh, it was
lot more fun now when you go away.
Okay. And you're, you're in
that, what, what prison did
you go to? I was in several.
I started out in Fcc New York. I did
two years there waiting to be sentenced.
So that's a state, it's, it's
diff 10 all federal, federal.
And then it's not the camp that
you think it is, by the way.
And then I was sent out to Mariana
Florida and uh, that's nice weather.
Well, there's 105 in the summer.
I had to go outside. Oh yeah. No.
What happened was I was in isolation
for nine months in nine months in total
isolation in MCC, New York.
And what is that like?
It's the worst thing in the world.
It's total deprivation
and sensory deprivation.
Every it's lights on all
the time. Uh, not always,
but depending upon the
location you were at,
sometimes they keep a light
on so that they can see you,
you know, so, you know, so,
but it does it feel
like the worst thing is,
the worst thing about being in isolation
is your loss of interpersonal skills,
which I, I don't know if I have any, any
way, but it just, when you pass people,
like in a physical manner, you don't
know whether they're going to stab you.
You should stay up there and he should
hug them. You should shake their hand.
It's, it's total. Um,
it's hard to explain,
but it's like that physical presence of
another person next to you and you in
your space. I mean you're, you're
a fighter. You know, you're a cop.
Someone gets in a certain space,
you need to protect yourself.
But being a convict slash inmate,
slash,
prisoner when someone steps
in your personal space,
of course you need to check them,
but when you're in isolation
you don't know what it is.
Like your personal space becomes
whatever you can grasp whenever you can
control.
So when I was first example was my
first pass somebody, we had a room,
let's say the size of your
studio here and he was like,
he was out on the floor and I was
out on the floor at the same time,
which is very odd, my situation because
I never was, I wasn't around anybody.
I didn't know what to do. You know,
how to respond to his presence in my,
in my world.
And he was another guy that was also in
solitary for a short period until he was,
he just got in trouble for something.
But at that point I was probably getting
at that moment probably five or six
months when I was five or six months with
no contact, except when they feed you.
Right. And when they feed
you, they talked to, you know,
they throw the food through a slot and
you go, no one says anything to you.
Very little, very little interaction.
How are you today? You know? Yeah. Good.
I'm good. Great. I just
finished another book. It okay,
so that's the entire extent of your
human interaction for nine months.
It's essentially, yes, I
do. You do get visits, uh,
once a week or something like that for
an hour. What? Your family members. Wow.
You know, that's, you know, it's a
little different cause she's, you know,
it's a warm thing, you know, but people
that are criminals, convicts and same,
you're not really touchy,
Lovey, feely type thing.
So you don't know how to respond,
you know? Yeah. I would imagine like,
but didn't Bradley Manning,
I think he was in for like two years
plus before he became Chelsea manning.
Right.
Two years plus solitary.
No interaction with anyone
at and I believe no clothes
because they were worried
about him killing himself or herself.
I don't know when,
when does the transition, when do you
officially say him or her? Either way,
but like I've heard it argued that like
you go insane.
Like if you,
if you leave someone alone for two or
three years and there's no interaction at
all with other people, yeah. You
might as well just fucking shoot.
You guys used to sleep
underneath their bed,
put the mattress on top of the bed
and sleep underneath it underneath.
Like there's the bed. We
hang up the walls. I Dunno, I
didn't want to ask him. Wow.
It was just like, that's what they
life became. You become insane. They,
pappy mason is at one of
the guys that he killed her
competent. Uh, it was responsible
for the killing of Eddie Burns.
I think one of the,
one of the offices that was executed
and he used to sleep under his bed.
It was part of the fact
that he wanted to be,
you know,
him to be cycled rather than be
responsible for what he was doing things.
But then it became him. Ooh. Yeah.
It's dreads were fucking
like 12 feet long.
He's life became whatever, you know, I
have no sympathy for what, but he did.
But just people,
human beings in general.
That's what happens when they start
to go on the other side of that. Well,
the thing about the Bradley manning cases,
if more fucked up cause,
cause all he did was exposed crime.
I mean that was the guy who gave away
the wikileaks documentary. Oh, documents.
Okay. And he gave it to Julian
Assange's. Now they're both fucked.
He's the Julian Assange just stuck in a
fucking embassy in London. He can't move.
They just recently,
I think in the last couple of days,
they got rid of his 24 hour guards,
had guards outside the gate making sure
he didn't bolt and now and now they're
like, yeah, fuck he stays, he's done.
Yeah. It wasn't gonna go stuck in this,
I think the Ecuador Embassy.
And, uh, so he's fucked there.
And then Chelsea manning is fucked in
jail forever and they're never going to
let her out now.
And that's it.
And it's all exposing crime,
which is even more fucked up because
Julian Assange is not a criminal.
Bradley Manning, he's not a
crowd other than, you know,
the crime of exposing government
corruption and documents.
I'll give you an interesting detail
and one of the hundreds of stories,
uh, my boys, they do a
shakedown. They, they hit, they
hit, they robbed this Bodega,
which is why chickie and Walter become my
buddy. I mentioned it briefly before. So
they're out on bail. Walt is living in
my house and Trimboli one of the, uh,
internal affairs detective
is constantly at my house,
like surveilling my house and
Shit. Right. And Walter, uh,
chickies out on bail, getting ready
to do a little nine month bit.
Walter's getting ready to go upstate for
two and a half years cause he's like,
he was on duty and he was the police
officer that was still on the job. And um,
so
I find out that they get
ready to go to trial.
Now they're all putting herself,
this is prior to them please.
They get ready to go to trial. So I get
in touch with Barron and I tell Baron,
tell the owner to Bodega that he needs
to leave the country right away because
trials coming up in a week.
So
barren reaches out and tells the guy that,
you know,
the cops stopped by my office today and
said, you guys got to leave the country.
You know, you got to leave the
country. And he says, and you know,
you gotta leave because things can get
bad if you don't leave the country.
So guy leaves country.
Immediately I got a phone
call from one of the guys,
whether it was Walter with
chickie says to fucking trials,
but they don't know the trial has
been postponed. I said, okay, good.
I don't know the details, but
I know he's gone. The Guy,
I'd had them leave the country.
So
about eight or 10 months later,
the case is ready to fall apart.
Internal Affairs goes and arrests
this guy's wife or sister.
She's working some bookies spot, uh,
one of those bodegas that sales numbers.
And didn't really sell
food. And uh, the rest,
his wife tell them they're
gonna deport her and take her,
keep her kids and put them in PC.
BCW One of those bureau of Child Welfare.
So we'll call you, call your brother
and tell him to get back. Yeah,
I can't come back. They're going
to have me killed by the Aba.
So he comes back on the protection
and the trial goes forward.
But the fact is that what I'm getting at
and what I'm telling you is that's what
you can actually do when you were a cop.
If you really don't want
something to happen,
you could actually have that kind
of control over a situation. Well,
because I mean, it wasn't them who
did it. It was, it was us who did it.
We had this guy leave the country.
So these are the stories
that the book layout or,
or even if the movie takes a
spin in that direction, I mean,
there's really some intense shit
that we were able to do. I mean,
if a guy put a complaint in against us,
we call it was house,
you know,
if you wanted to complain that the cop
some treated me unfairly or something
like that. Really, you know,
you got to realize what
you were dealing with.
Well that kind of shit
goes on to this day,
that kind of subtle versions of that.
I,
I'm not looking at disparage anybody here.
I'm just telling you what we were able
to do by understanding in order to keep
our moving the ball forward. Right. You
know, that's the way you could do things,
you know, uh, if I put it, what they
call the civilian complaint in against,
let's say yourself and you are my either
my, my buddy, one of my coworkers,
you're not going to go to the guy's
house and you know, and say anything,
but you might have your friends sit in
front of his house for a week and just
freak them out. You, I have
to do anything. Right. I think
it's enough. It's pretty,
it's pretty clear how we did
that. The cello, the, the,
uh, the kingpin drug dealer.
And then that's when he tried to threaten
to kill me, man for the movie. Get Out.
He put her head on me because I sat in
front of his Bodega cause he showed her
the $700. I sat in front
of his Bodega for, um,
all week probably,
and then he notified Barron
that he put a hit out on me.
I don't know if that was part of the
fluff for the reality is so barren and
called me and he says,
there's a hit on you.
So that's when I went and I found them
the next day and day one, whatever it was,
and uh, pulled them over and, uh,
confronted him in the street. And uh,
he called it off and got my 700 bucks
though, which was a nice day. Kenny says,
I never gave him the three 50. He's
got to be full of Shit. I mean, what?
And he that he, oh, he wasn't there. Like
I said, I'm not sure. I don't remember,
you know. Wow. Um, now
when you go away, okay,
you do your nine months in solitary,
right. Why did they put you in solitary?
Initially cop, because you're a
cop, but just to protect you. Yeah.
So once you get out of solitary, yeah.
Now you're in with everybody else.
And what is that like?
Yeah.
Should I go back? Solid area is
this maximum security, minimum,
maximum high security.
So you're dealing with everybody
that was in late with the guys.
So you named him their names there
that I was there with them. You know,
the [inaudible] crew
was on the 11th floor.
I was on the ninth floor or the seventh
floor, you know, and MCC and uh,
so I mean guys,
for whatever,
all the gang bangers were in there
that were around that time. You know,
some of my good buddies, we're were, were
cop impersonators, you know, they were,
uh, one of those gangs that was
going out, basically executing.
I was an executing anybody,
but they were, you know,
they were going in his cops and execute
and the drug dealers taking their money.
So they going in with lights,
the whole deal. All badges,
coach bulletproof vests,
38 Smith and Wessons and taking people,
killing people and taking their drugs.
I mean that was the 80s.
And it's Brooklyn and Manhattan
and the Bronx. And when,
when you're in there and you
go from solitary to just,
just general population or a population
or watch it back every to every step of
the way, what does that, what
does that like? Eh, you know,
it's like how when I was driving to work
one and if I was getting arrested every
day,
what was the first day like the first day?
Like they let you out and now all of a
sudden do you have to share a cell with
somebody? Yeah. Who was
the, um, I can't recall.
You don't know who you should have
saw with that? There was hundreds.
Hundreds of guys. Yeah. Just different
gods all times. All the time.
We were in transition in MCC, New
York. You're in transition. You know,
I ended up sharing a cell with patsy conti
one time was one of the wise guys. Uh,
you know,
they tried to keep the white guys
with the white guys cause prisons very
racially divided, divisive, you
know, black guys with black guys,
white guys with white guys. That's
how it, how it was, you know,
Spanish guys and Spanish guys,
you know.
So that's just the way prison now
do you have to align yourself with a
particular groups or anything while
you're in this and no one's going to lend
themselves with me, you know, but happen
chances that when you're in MCC, New York,
it's like
60% black guys,
35% Hispanic guys,
2% Asian and 1% white.
So thank you.
Missing some numbers.
Don't hold me to the, let me
get my pen out. So it was, yeah.
And so like, even if you were a wise
guy in the street, you saw a white face,
you know, you talked whether you liked
each other or not, you know, I understand.
And you know, being that with young
and still a little, uh, you know, not,
I was pretty good shape at this point.
Now down about a year or so
and doing probably, you know,
push 600 800 pushups, pushups a
day, Chin ups, dips, back, bends,
and the whole bit, right? Right now
I'm in great shape. I'm doing the bar,
I'm doing 160 Chet pullups a,
you know what's backwards and people see
you moving around. They're like, okay,
you know, this isn't an easy trip.
Right, right, right. No matter how,
what do you think of me? It was a cop and
I, it wasn't an easy ride. So, and then,
you know, all the older wise guys, you
know, their feeble guys, most of them,
when he finally got arrested,
most of them are banged up anyway.
There's 65 70 you know, and what happens
to those guys when they get in? Well,
they align themselves with a young guy
does most of their bidding and hopefully
you don't have to take a knife for one
of them or something like that. But look,
they got money when you've got money in
prison, it's like money in the street,
you know, and when you're in, okay.
So when you go from being in
solitary to general population,
like what are your days like? What did
well, there's different worlds, you know,
MCC, new neocon, you're in a
jail, so you're really just
inside the building and,
and, and, and some people have jobs,
some people don't jog meetings.
They go to the kitchen,
they cook and they provide meals for
the rest of the prison. I was in a,
like an orderly, I have to clean a
floor or something like that. And um,
basically sat there and waited and took
it sentenced. It was horrible. You know,
you sat inside a building,
you know you're coming. Yeah.
It looked like a piece of paper white.
You got no son,
you got no vitamin C or D or B,
e or g,
whatever the fuck the
vitamins are from the sun.
They got none of them and the food's
horrible and you can't wait to get
sentenced.
Right.
Cause you want to go out and live a life
now being sentenced prisoner opposed to
a prisoner in waiting like a bride and
waiting, you finally get out. You know?
So how long has this waiting period was?
Two years.
So for two years or nine
months instead of military.
And then another year or 15 months,
you're just in this jail waiting to be
sentenced. So finally get sentenced.
Once they get sent to I get put on a lia
jet. It was like first class I could,
yeah,
I could take it from MCC new you'll
welcome to in a limousine prison limousine
to over to uh, um, uh, Teterboro airport
with a, with a federal jet is Lia jet.
Me and like two other people
get on this jet and we,
they whisk us off to a
two people. Yeah. W Yeah,
they whisk us off to Florida. We land in
Jacksonville. We pick up some, some girl,
I don't know.
And then the Wisconsin West.
So this is how they transport prisoners.
They put them in a federal jet. Yeah.
Yeah. Wouldn't my case in my case, because
I was getting, I was leading the, the,
the, the region. They have
a big bus. Normally they'll,
they'll deposit yet along the way.
And then some people get moved
around on different size jets. Just,
this happened to be a, which is like four
or five passenger jet, which was nice,
but I have done that. I'm sorry,
federal, like a VIP and this is right.
This is great. I love this.
Peanuts, nuts, lots of nuts,
but no peanuts.
So then it was a cute girl on the
fucking playing with me. I'm like, well,
isn't that a girl prisoner? How'd that
work out? I don't remember her name,
but anyway, she was cute and
you have to look at something.
She just elbow me a little bit.
You know? Where's she? I Dunno.
To a woman's prison in Tallahassee.
What does she do?
I don't know if we don't
talk to ask her questions,
but I'm fucking trying to keep my,
my world smaller. When you were,
when you were a guy like me in prison,
you don't open your mouth.
You don't talk to anybody. You don't
elicit a conversation with anybody.
That'd be really difficult for
you, I would imagine. Horrible.
It was like pulling my tongue out and
throw it on the ground for fucking 12
years. So you just doing
this for survival purposes,
state your own little world you open,
cause he opened yourself up.
People want either in or to to
use things against you. You know,
like in the ref free world. But in this
case there, it's a microcosm. Right.
You know,
if come back to your real quick,
the way people use information
against you. Wow. So, so I,
so I feel from there and then I ended
up in some small county jail, uh,
which I ended up with one of the guys
from cocaine cowboy who ends up dying. Uh,
if you bought it from, a couple of them
did. But this fella, he was telling me,
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here and
I'm in the county jail. And he's like,
well a piece of Barb wire around this
fence and he's telling me there's a guy in
a, in a, in a, in a tree tree house. It's
like I get a tree house with a shotgun.
That's it. A shotgun. Yeah. That's
it. What's security for this?
For this little county jail,
but their shotgun. Yeah.
He said that they would show far away.
Is he
60 80 feet from the Bob white
fence? Oh yeah. Some kill Ya.
16 Gotcha.
If he's not sleeping,
but they're only making 10 $12,000
a year. Oh. So he's saying,
and he's big money cocaine count.
We guys,
he's thinking he could have some
money sent to this guy's fucking,
I don't know his mother.
Who the fuck knows?
All you have to do is give the
guy something to puts him out.
If some chew tobacco,
you just give them a
pill that knocks him out.
Like tell him you're going to hit
me responsible. I'm gonna give you,
I'm going to dummy up your dress and
I'm going to jump and no one's going to
know how it happened. You're going to
wake up. We should huddle of your own.
He said, done time together. That's where
I would have done. This is real simple.
Here go 48 you know these guys,
I mean, they weren't that young,
but these guys, you know, they wouldn't,
they were already fighting for
their lives. When El Chapo,
when that guy got out and he dug
that hole a mile long run underneath,
they gave him a pill. No, but didn't
you respect that? I respect that.
I'm not even put pot.
The fact that they had the fucking the
thought process involved and this is no,
but I mean still,
I was like I gotta respect it.
Had to know that I made a fucking mile
long tunnel willing tricity the money
you'll get wet when you got that kind
of money you're getting out. Okay.
And there's a lot of people getting
paid to along the way that he's got a
hundred million dollar bounty
on Donald Trump. Oh really?
Trump talk shit about Mexicans too much.
Let's not talk politics here
cause political assassinations
are political too.
But when guys want to get out,
you know and you all day all that's all
you're thinking about the stuff they
were digging out more. I was too, but
they stick out. They caught them. Yeah.
The thing it was someone
gets you up right?
Cause they cause they want to go to with
a better place. Like, like, let's say you,
I mean, I ended up in Mariana, well
let me, let me tell you this. Okay.
So we get off the bus and I'm like,
this is going to be fucking horrible.
I can do another now at this point,
another,
the 10 and a half years like this walking
the fucking place like this and it's
hot. It's fucking the middle of the
summer. Like I say, July, whatever it was,
and panhandle of Florida, it's
fucking hot. It's a hundred.
And I get off the bus and I see this,
you know this fence and gate and shit
and then it looks okay, you know,
and they bring you into r. And.
D. It's like you're a package.
They're bringing into R. And, d,
they process you, they give you the,
if you had to see him on TV,
they got the fucking bags,
they've got their bedroll dead role in
their hand that has something that glows
and Shit, and you're walking through
this compound and this God opens a God,
whatever pack he opens up the,
the report to this compound.
And I say to myself,
strike me dead now.
I just came from a fucking hole
in the wall for years. Right?
Two years I've been looking at nothing
but cement and Polish on the floor and he
opens it up and I see the
luscious fucking place I problem.
Other than the my vacations
in the Cayman Islands,
this was the most picturesque
place I've ever seen.
Like up close and in person
now it doesn't matter.
It's two years I've been seeing cement.
So I mean lush flowers
call is beautiful grass,
beautiful cement. Gorgeous. A big
beautiful Chow Hall. What my name?
My name's st come and eat.
You know I haven't had a good meal and
fucked him forever. And the food was good.
I was eating fucking Hash, right? Food's
going to be good in a lot of Wa wa.
So I go like this, I go to myself,
I know this is fucking paradise.
Swear to God. I just finished
saying it and the God goes,
welcome to Paradise. Whoa. Like this.
Like the thing we have to
know code hilarious and I'm
going to this fucking guy.
I don't want to let them know
that I agree. Why fucking agree.
So when he's saying welcome to Paris,
he fucking with you or is he know
because he knows where I just came fry.
You understand? And he knows that
this, this is nice. It's a, it's a,
it's a college campus with fences
around it, you know, but the habit,
the inhabitants are not quite right.
You know,
the average sentence was,
uh,
I think 18 years when I worked in that
place and it was 300 and I want to say 40
some odd men that would never going home
that it was, now I'm going to bunk with,
okay, those are the dangerous ones. Right.
You know what, that Elise dangerous,
there were nothing to lose guys,
not the ones that are doing their time,
you know, why are they
the least dangerous? Well,
because they just want to live
their lives out. You know,
with the young bucks that you know
that to just want to make a name for
themselves and that they don't see,
they don't see the 10 years,
15 years from now,
they're going home.
They just see the same immediate
gratification that got them there.
So right now I like your sneakers or
I like your fucking soup, you know,
and I don't have any soup cause my
parents, I don't even know my parents.
You know what I mean? And so I
don't get the extras, you know,
prisons about extras. You know, if you
get extras in prison, you'll, you'll,
you know, so explain that
to me. Commissary. You know,
people live on commissary
in prison because it's like,
it's like as part of rebellion,
no one wants to be beholden to the
government for what they're going to give
them. So when you go into prison, yeah,
you'd get good square meal, you know,
food's okay. You know, it's cooked
for fucking 1800 men. Right.
There's plenty of it. It's
a control mechanism. Okay.
Food is a control mechanism,
exercises,
control mechanism and all the frills
that control mechanisms and how do you
control population, water, food,
sex that they can't have. So certain
things are controlled mechanism,
food and exercise in prison
as a control mechanism. So
the way to control guys is to, to, to
provide them with, with a good meal.
And you don't want to lose
that good fucking meall. Right.
So you're gonna be good.
Cause cause I just came from a
place where I was eating shit of a,
of a plastic container all day long.
Now I get a plate with a knife and a fork.
I can eat like a gentleman. You know,
you start to feel like a
human being again. But upon
with the guy, next years is,
you know, you don't want to take
him home necessarily, you know,
so he listens to me. The guy next to
you is not getting the same food. No,
he's getting the same and he wants
that. Right. So he went to keep the,
maintain the status quo. So if he's
down there doing a life sentence,
he's okay with this cause he's accepted
it. It's the young guys that think that,
you know, they want your
food or they, you know,
they want to get over the
good that get over mentality.
You have to let go of
that get over mentality.
Otherwise you're going to live that
fucking happy life in prison and get over
mentality. Meaning you're always looking
to get ahead a little bit. Scam a little,
this scam a little easier.
Some mags sell them to this guy.
A lot of people send
money home from prison,
so it turns into another rat race that
you know. When you say the commissary,
like what? What do you, what can
you get at a connoisseur? Well,
one of the biggest things stamps,
so he can use that to bought her stamps
is currency stamps into an official
currency in prison. So you could
send letters, you can send letters.
So you have to have stamps, scandal,
you can gamble to come. Yeah, right.
What kind of gambling? Well, sports,
usually it's sports gambling and then
there's cards, you know, and it's called,
it's a checkers and chess, you
know, people gamble on anything.
So can you watch games
and stuff like that? Well,
the unit I stayed in had five or six
TVs really in, in a common area. Yeah.
One had the rap station on,
one had a basketball all the time
and the other one had Spanish TV.
So then you had CNN once in a while,
which we sold the nine 11 attack and it
will come out looking at me, my eyes.
Did you see what happened?
I'm like, uh, okay. You know,
they look to you because you were a cost.
Of course I was from New
York and I was oh right.
You know all the staff and everybody came
over. You know, that was, it was, it was,
it was a difficult fucking moment
to say the least. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I went to a lot of
that stuff in prison.
So when the comments are you can get
extra things. That's for food after food.
Yeah. What kind of food? Like I
said, tuna, fish, octopus. Oh yeah.
Some places. Yeah. So yeah, we got
to buy it. How much does it cost?
If you paid a dollar for a tuner and
the street, it was two 50 in the air.
Let that type of thing, you know,
or whatever the current rate is.
You paid a little bit more
in prison. Yeah. And then
if you're working in prison,
you very little money,
you get very little money.
So the money from the outside
is what you'll be maintained.
So guys that go to prison and have
outside connections with family that would
still help them support themselves become
a commodity in prison. So you know, you,
you're a hustler in prison,
so you,
you would like to take extra
eggs and make some exile.
Let's say it cause the guys work
out all day long. It's what they do,
increase their protein,
they want to stay in shape because
they want to go home one day, you know?
And so you learn to adjust your life
in order that you have an end game.
Some kids only cared about today,
you know, and they signed him,
don't go home because they ended up
getting in a fight or stabbing, killed,
whatever. And then they get another
bid, they get on the bed because I had,
and there you go.
So is that what you did most of
your time down there in Florida?
Five years plus in Marianna, Florida. And
then I wanted to get closer to family,
you know, so cause I was
getting ready to be Libby least,
that had not been seven years.
I am anticipating and release
in about three or four years,
which didn't turn out. And, uh, I
lost a year when I got on a plane,
which is a legal argument that I made for
the next five years and lost. But, uh,
I wanted a year off down in Marianna,
Florida for my drug program participation
and, but had to go to court to get it.
So when I got on a plane to come back
to Devon's Massachusetts where I served,
uh, in a or mass, and if you're familiar
with that area of Massachusetts at all,
whereas air, what's air?
It's near from the W uh,
fort Devins on, um, it's, it's a,
it's west West of Boston,
about 45 miles. Okay.
Washed, washed Worcester. It's near
worse demand. Okay. Um, anyway,
so they had to open a new federal prison
there and I want to get closer to my
family. So I ended up getting on a plane.
You know, you request, you make a request,
got on a plane, they've fulfilled
my request. They ended up in Devon,
Massachusetts.
And when I got off the plane,
I lost a year off of my sentence because
I now know different legal jurisdiction
than the legal jurisdiction
that I was in in Florida too.
You have to do an extra
year because of it.
So I got the put back onto my sentence
Dierdorf and I just wanted to fucking, ah,
I was on fucking medications and
it's like, it's like you, I said,
can you just send me
back? They went, no. Oh
yeah.
So I love the federal house to come to
New York because I wanted to be closer to
my family, so they would get to
know me as I get released, you know,
get closer bond that you family,
make it easier,
make it easy for everybody
visiting a, exactly. And then,
so of course we another the year,
so I ended up in a fight over that
and physical fist fight, whatever.
I lost my fucking mind.
And they ended up causing a hunger
strike because a hunter, you,
you want to understand that I organized
one, it wasn't a bad, I couldn't do,
I can't go six hours without eating.
I'm getting hungry right now.
I help organize a hunger strike and
I organize a hundreds hunger strip.
He didn't participate.
I participated for an hour.
I got locked up in an hour. You
don't know. The stories are crazy.
So I ended up in, uh, in MCC, New
York again, a place where I had just,
oh no, back in the fucking hole
over there in isolation. Oh,
Michael is another hunger strike
there. Oh God. And not done.
They listened to us and uh,
they shipped me out to Mckeon,
Pennsylvania and I did like three
years there. I mean, it just gets old.
It gets tired just going through the
shit and you live the life out there and
you know, I don't need any sympathy by
the way. Just, it is what it is, you know?
Yeah. I know. I'm not
giving you any sample that,
I'm just trying to think about it.
What it was like to add a
year to someone's sentence. I,
they actually called for an ambulance
after he told me, you want an ambulance?
I'm like, I'm not sure. I
was going down like, right.
I don't know what happens.
It was like,
get up for five years to get this fucking
four years to get the sentence reduced.
The here and now you're getting
it back to me in one day when I,
cause I got off a plane and you're
bucking state. I hate this fucking state.
Send me back to Florida. I know you
got, you got, here's the good news.
She says to me, this bitch,
she goes, here's the good news.
The good news is you've got
four years to fight us. Ooh,
I just got finished fight number
four years. Oh, of course.
So much to fight these
cocksuckers you have no idea.
And I'm living on stamps and the goodwill
of people sending me money and some of
the money that I earned in prison,
you know, just fucking horrible.
Now are you allowed to make
money off of your case now? Um,
I did a lot of research. My, the
people I'm involved with and you know,
unless there's a specific victim
that was specifically out there,
unless the guy says I stole his
kilos, you know, I don't know.
What's he going to do though?
Say you'd have to prove how many kilos
you sold or didn't get that I, you know,
so, so it's not like
a violent crime, like,
like Oj Simpson can't make
money off us. Yes. Right.
But the details are slightly different
because, you know, I was, uh,
I don't know why I would fuck you would
call it, but you know, the people that,
that research for me said that there is
the law that some that's understandable
does not directly affect you.
Yeah. It would make sense.
You have to have a specific thing that
you victimized and then you profit off of
that for their misinformation. Right,
right, right. That you caused, right.
Yeah.
So this is not that this is the son,
the same executed people on
island, you know, in fact, the guy,
the detective's name is a distant
cousin of mine, Timothy Dow,
to the rest of them. Really? Yeah. That's
called the son of Sam. Yeah. Yeah. So,
you know, my family's got the legacy
on both sides, I guess. Pro Con. Um,
now, what is it like the first
day he got out? You know,
I thought you might ask that
question. [inaudible] yeah. Uh, well,
the first day I got out, um, know
there's this, this different outs. Okay,
you get rid of it, you get released to
a halfway house. So I was in Mckean,
Pennsylvania.
Now if I finish with my bed and my,
my parents wanted to send a limousine
to pick me up and welcome me home,
like a big shot, you know, but not,
not in a boisterous way, just just to,
just to show me, they show
me love, show me love. Right.
So I said, you know what, no,
I want to take the bus home,
the gray hound. So I got on
a Greyhound bus and I, uh,
drove the gray him. I didn't
drive at night. Like I,
it was a passenger on a greyhound
bus to, to MCC, MCC, the bus,
the bus terminal in new, in Manhattan.
And my family was there waiting for me.
You know, about 10, 15 of them were
there. It was. It was a nice welcoming,
but all I can do is say I need a quarter.
And they're like,
what do you need a quarter four? I said,
I need to fucking make a phone call.
I said, can anyone got a quarter?
I got, I need it right now.
I'm panicking because I'm running late
and they halfway house and I'm a rule
follower at some time,
so I don't want to go back.
So I need to notify the halfway house.
I'm gonna be running late
because the bus was late. Right.
So all of a sudden people start handing
me these things to talk on what the
fuck? Cell phones, the phone.
I go look up, dial it from
me. I never dial up. I don't
know what I'm doing. Right.
So you'd never seen a cell
phone before? Never swore. If
I tell home, I'm like, wow,
that's not true. I showed the original
cell phones, the brick, the bricks.
I was debating on the handle of the
bricks, but now I had no idea what,
you should have one of those things. No,
but my drug dealers did. Oh, all those,
they have those like the ones
from Gordon Gekko in Wall Street.
They look like this.
It was squared and then they had
the ones with the long cords,
they could talk on it. It has a
suitcase. They were my heroes.
I'm calling my house from my wife's going,
what are you calling from? I go, I'm,
you don't want the book deal was cell
phones right now. The guys, like I said,
20 favorite race,
that number when I finished talking.
So you call it the halfway house and
now you have to have to live there for
which is back in the ghetto.
I'm back in the ghetto,
living in a halfway house and a amount
about, I don't know, two, three days and,
and, and uh, the news, the newspaper would
front circle and like fucking, you know,
bees around honey flies on shit.
They're all over the place.
And then someone snaps a picture,
a guy puts it up front page
of the Daily News and said,
doubts still walks like a comp.
It wasn't me. You walked her car.
What the fuck does that mean?
Well, you know, we know.
They know what they're saying.
Own a baton.
One white guy and they get a welcome.
Like I owned it.
And so this guy was interesting,
but it wasn't even in your lesson.
Maybe somebody else should the guy
shoes and get to half a million.
I'm still broke. Really? Yeah.
That guy sued and got a half a million
dollar walking like a cop. It was,
they put his picture on the front page
of the, Oh, that's a miss. And they,
and they tarnished just criminal
image that said he was a rogue cop.
He was only there for something
else. That's hilarious. Yes.
So he had to deal with that as the daily
news wrote. What was it? Which one?
That was the daily news. Wow,
man. Man, man, man, you go, well,
how's that? Enough said when people,
yeah, people don't know those,
those tabloid newspapers in New York,
those are hilarious newspapers.
The fucking covers are always very funny,
right.
Not when your face is on it for
fucking like six months. Yeah.
Well I would imagine, did you
save any of those? No, but yes.
No, I mean I didn't want to cabinet my
property when I landed in a different
institution like, oh, oh this is,
you just put these up on the wall.
Some family members had
like every one I guess.
But now when you get out and
you're in the halfway house,
I want to go down and you have to stay
on and go back to prison. Really? Yeah.
Cause the halfway house that bad. No,
because I don't know what to do it.
So you were institutional. I'm done.
Yeah, I'm cold. I'm cold. This is not,
that's what they always say cooked.
I don't know what to do or how to do.
I don't have to walk across the street
and I'm afraid because if I walk across
it, don't walk. Sign. I'm standing there.
Imagine standing in Brooklyn
in front of it. Don't walk.
Sign for like five minutes and
there's no fucking cards upstanding.
They're waiting for the don't walk.
So I had to turn, so the hand,
they have to handle the
future someone and doing,
he was doing anything wrong because
they're following me everywhere I go. Why?
I don't want the newspeople
snapping a picture of me walking up,
girls against the don't walk sign sort
of toast guy comes up to me and says,
Mike, I looked at him. Yeah, I don't want
acknowledgement, but when do I look like?
He goes, can you just sign
this affidavit for me that you,
that that this issue that I'm about to
take your picture of? I call them on.
I got to do your fucking job.
Leave me alone.
Please sign and date because the other
guy just sued the fucking Daily News.
That's hilarious. Hilarious. That's
hilarious. I'm taking a shower.
This is my epic moment.
I first shower and freedom.
I talk about this often because it's epic
and I'm looking out the window and he
was my brother's two kids.
I don't know these kids and I've met them.
My mother's side and my
mother's apartment upstairs,
my mother's house upstairs looking out.
The shower has a window I'm looking at
and I see these two little kids running
across my brother's living next door.
My brother was a cop.
He retired because of me, but he'd
got a pension. Thank God. Anyway,
that's another story. Play
good hockey player. So that's
where he got his pension.
Anyway,
so
I see these two kids and uh, I
realized the loss that, you know,
I mean the whole world took place while
I walked that track by myself, you know,
and my brother who idolized me to no end
now has two kids and I don't even know
mine. And I'm like, oh my
God, this is fucking horrible.
And now I've got to make a living and the
first thing I want to do is help those
that I left behind. You
know, yours truly included.
And I'm like,
I don't think I can do this.
And I'm in the fucking shower
crying so hard that I don't know.
I'm getting wet from the
shower or my tears and like,
I don't know if you've ever cried in your
life. I'm a man. I can say it. You know,
I've never, I don't cry.
Okay. I've wept so hard.
I wept so hard that I wanted
to take a nap when I was done.
It was just like, I was like, Shit,
just kept pouring out of my body.
The first shower and freedom was like I
was getting all the poison of life now
because you know, you gotta realize
this is at this time of 44 years old,
I have nothing.
Zero.
My whole life is a fucking
zero at 44 years old.
But you still have kids and I don't
feed anything, but you're out.
I have nothing. I don't have
kids. Someone else has kids.
I happened to be a guide that
they heard about. I have nothing.
It'd
be easier for me to turn around
and go back. Wow. So do you,
you really wanted to go back? Of course.
I didn't want to. You didn't want,
it just seemed like the easiest thing to
do was to go back and thank God at that
moment I had good parents and solid family
support and couple of young kids that
wanted to get to know
me. You know? Uh, cause
that's, I don't know what
else to say. I mean it just,
it was like I didn't know what to do.
I had to do to earn a living.
I never had a fucking job.
And my life, I was a cop.
So what did you do for a job after that?
Because it's gotta be hard to get a job.
I still can't get a job.
Do you want one?
Well, you got one from me. If I had, when
I give it to you, I just, I'm a good word.
I need a real podcast network.
That's what I need.
I need to actually have a network.
Yeah. We start, give, give,
giving guys like you shows.
I couldn't get a fucking job,
but my brother was doing some construction
and then I get mixed up with the
construction industry for about four
or five years and I did pretty well.
And that was in the boom time,
so anybody could hold the brush in
their hand or a hammer in their hand,
got a job and they made a decent salary.
And I turned down some union office
because I had family that runs one of the
unions on. And I turned it down
because I needed money now.
I wanted to try to help now. And,
um, so I did what I call it and um,
and uh, you know, listen, I I,
I put an ankle bracelet on me when I got
home cause I was banging on the chicks
from the halfway house.
You're not supposed to do that,
but you're not supposed to
know. Why not? I don't, I don't,
I don't they own you are, you're free.
You're not. No, cause she's a convict too.
So can't associate with convicts.
Right.
But you're sleeping in the
house with them. Right. But
you can't fuck them. Right.
Can you hug them? No. No.
Patronize and [inaudible] or
sexualizing any of them. Well,
so it was very difficult. I broke the
rule from the day. So the first rule.
So did you get in trouble for that?
Yes. Breaking that rule. Eventually.
What do they do?
What do they say?
I tried to get rid of her because she was
a psycho. I found out, uh, gee, how weird.
Psycho ex con, that doesn't
even make sense. It makes sense.
And I want to talk disparagingly about
the dead by the way. She passed. Oh,
what happened? Yeah, I think I
don't live or something anyway,
but hold them horrible death. But,
uh, I had to get away from her,
so I made the decision to go
back to prison just to get
away from her real. Yeah.
And uh,
she threatened to call and she did,
she called my probation officer and he
came in a put an ankle bracelet on me.
He spared me prison.
He put an ankle now and then I got you
ended up again with the ankle bracelet on
because like I said, it was going
to church, but I didn't, uh,
where'd you go? I don't want to put
it out there. Okay. But it wasn't bad.
It was at someone's house,
you know, it's getting late.
I understand that because they wouldn't
leave my house. So finally I got out.
And so you were under house
arrest? Is that what the uh, the,
I could price it does, it keeps you up
within, within a beacon of the machine.
Yeah. So I was willing to
go back to prison to get rid
of this relationship and,
um, uh, um, I almost did. Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
So that was my reentry into society.
So how much time do you have to spend
doing this halfway house thing before
that's like it. But what it is, you go
from halfway house, the home confinement,
and then after home confinement you
go on to supervise, release home,
can find it so you can find your home
for during the, during the hours of the,
like if you're not working for now that
you're locked in your house, you know,
and that's, yeah. Yeah. So they can
call at any minute. And he said,
you can't go to the movies.
You can ask for permission to go shopping
and things of that nature, you know,
and then come back in. It's,
you're clocked, you checked
constantly on your toes.
I don't understand that. Like why is
that? If you're afraid, if you're free,
and if you can go to the movies was
you're not free. You're not free.
You're not free yet.
You're still part of your sentence.
It was just why I said 12 and a half
years, not 11 years, nine months,
because the last six months of my
prison sentence was in the street. Wow.
And then from there you do five
years of supervised released,
which is when she called up on me
when I broke up with her, you know,
and then he was fucking pissed as, I mean,
how could you blame the guy? You know,
I been trying to him for like two,
three years now at this point when she
can drop the dime on me. Let's pause.
He says, he says, well, I'm
gonna tell you. He said, what
do you mean? I said, look,
you're going to tell the judge that
I, I fell in love. Come on. Yeah,
she was the love judge. Judge,
judge, Judge Kimba what?
The ones who got it was all over the news.
What happened to her?
I don't know that story. I don't want
to talk bad about judges. You know?
I may see him again. Well, you don't have
to talk bad. No, she, she got jammed up.
Whatever relationship she was
wanting and it was all their news.
They dispatch to understand.
That's what I thought. Nope.
It's not quite as understanding
as you think hypocrites.
How dare they. So then
how do you, what do,
what do you eventually want
up doing for, for work? Um,
so I continue on in the construction
field and um, uh, I can't remember.
No, I can see continue on
in this limousine driving,
I ended up being a limousine driver.
The job that Kenny actually got me fired
from before I went to prison because I
got the job done the
limousine for one hour,
but never drove the limo because my lip,
I don't want to tell the story.
I'm about to get a job
driving a limousine. So Kenny
goes, where are you working?
Where you working?
But he's wearing a wire and go,
I'm just talking to
driving a limo tomorrow.
I'll have some decent pay all the plants
about leaving the country, you're off.
Well you don't, don't even fucking
really knows the depth of this.
This is about round bail. So I go look
good. If I got a job down in limbo, I'm,
you know, six, 800 a week for now.
I had a lot of money coming in,
in rental incomes. I'm good cause it had
four homes and a condo on the ocean. And
so he turns around and he
says, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What do you fucking care where? He goes,
well in case I want a job. So I go,
well I tell him,
I don't know.
It was in the fucking newspapers
in deer park somewhere. Boom.
Next day to go to start the job. I'm on
my way. Yeah, I just bought the last $300.
I bought a suit. Black suit guy
goes, I go, I'm on my way. It's just,
I haven't heard from you to put the call
me. Tell me what time to be at the shop.
He goes, we've got a problem. I know.
What's the problem? He says, so I got
a visit. I go, what? He
goes, I got to visit.
They're going to open my books and my
taxes and leave me a new asshole if I give
you a job here. I said, you gotta
be kidding me, motherfucker.
I just spent my list 300 cash.
Cause the government takes
everything when they get you.
So now I can't even get a job fucking
doing a hat while I'm out on bail.
So I wouldn't have had the Desperado
to leave the fucking country.
So Kenny set that up. I don't
know. Allegedly. Possibly.
Probably. Probably. I'm sure.
Wow.
So it wasn't just wearing a wire
[inaudible] who is conspiring on going?
You know what? He fucking walks around.
He's saved someone's life. Yeah,
you're fucking ruined. Mine probably
saved it in a way to that. I'm not mad.
I just, you know, just, just be, just
this, keep it real. He saved my life and,
and whatnot. You know what are some
of the cops saved my life, right?
They locked me up. Right. Wow. I couldn't
get a fucking package after that.
You're sitting on a gold mine though.
You are sitting on a gold mine.
These fucking stories. Oh, it's fucking
ridiculous. If you just write it,
if you can you write, can you
type? I can do a lot of things.
You should shoulder hurts
though. Well, yeah. You keep
doing this. Keep doing this.
What's going on with,
I got to fucking two pins Stinger and
you're going to pitch two vertebrae.
What do you call this? Have
you ever, uh, do you know what,
I'm going to treat prep and treatment
right now. What are they doing for you?
I'm doing the third physical therapy act.
I've had some serious spinal shit.
Bulging discs and stuff working out. Yeah,
you can, uh, you can get rid of that.
I've got rid of it. A harmless sound
it right now I'm working on it.
It's a process. You just got
to do it slow. And you know,
spinal decompression is a big thing to
stretching, hanging by her neck and shit.
They have these, um, things that you can
actually set up. They're fairly cheap.
He just set them up on a door.
They hang off the back of the door
like a little chain. My actually,
my friend Denny has one that
he likes even better than that.
It's inflated actually.
And you put it on your neck and he's had,
he's got some spinal issues too
and it actually just lifted.
It's shade it,
you pump it up and it kind of lifts up
on your neck and stretches because a lot
of it is either injury or bad posture
and everything gets compressed and it
stays compressed and the distance pop out.
And what you got to do is
relieve some of that compression.
And one of the ways is these, I
have this one, it's like a harness.
I strap it under my chin, I velcro it
in place, and then I crank on it, click,
click, pulls my neck, click,
click pulls my nervous or afraid
that you might overdose him down. No,
no, no. It's not that.
It's not listen to change yourself
for a second. You're right.
But I appreciate the, the uh, medical
advice, you know, because I'm in pain,
but uh, the Mike down.com and
people can get my, um, uh,
they can download the um,
the seven five from my
website and Nafa I might get,
I might get 25 cents if they do that. So
did you, do you get a cut of that? Okay.
I had a little something
so it would be nice.
I'll definitely something to be nice.
I mean,
I lost my job due to the documentary.
What job was at a,
I was doing mechanical services in,
uh,
in a location that I'm still
in flux with them. Right?
Even when he fucking
describing a legit job,
everything is the problem is you
gotta understand something. Uh,
I lost the position because of my past.
So if I put their specific location,
I understand I,
and I'm still trying to work
something out with them. Right?
So they found out about your thing,
knew about it when they hired me,
but the documentary became
so compelling and riveting,
so interesting and so detailed that,
you know,
probably some cop called up and said,
I don't want my wife working with
this guy around and fucking CEO said,
you got to find a way to get
rid of him. Yeah. Well listen,
they're doing your favor. I swear to God,
you're sitting on a fucking gold mine.
These stories you have and you have,
I guarantee you probably have a fucking
thousand of them all your years in the
job. Easily. 10 years, 10 years, five
months. I didn't the street. Yeah.
You just need to sit down with somebody
and write these out and then edit them
and make the most compelling ones.
You could probably have a
fucking 500 page book. 500 yeah,
I'm trying to cut it down, cut it
down. But if you cut it down to d,
the gems and just,
you know,
honest about all the fucking craziness
and all the weird shit that's going on in
your head and the family and
Pussy and drugs and God damn,
it's a gold mine. I'll fucking buy it.
I'll buy it in the God damn heartbeat.
You know my friend Joey Diaz is
a, a a nut for crime books. He's,
he's turned me on like a fucking hundred
crime books. He's always like Joe Rogan.
You gotta read this fucking book
and had the kind of time to read.
Cause today people don't.
That's good. Once you get on
planes to yeah, planes out,
that's a good time.
If I just force myself a couple of days
a week to force myself to go to bed,
where before I go to bed, sit
down and, and that's, you know,
that's what I used to do in the joint.
I have,
I've had probably four or
500 books while I was away,
so I tried to expand my vocabulary.
However,
when you've talked to
welcome police terms,
you vocabulary narrows back to the
vocabulary you use while you're,
while you're doing your job. Yeah.
Like, fuck you, motherfucker.
Get over you and get that right now.
Let me see your fucking hands and
don't fucking move. Meanwhile,
I want you to raise your hands. Well,
the, um, audio books are great too.
I love that.
Cause I'm always stuck in traffic and
especially I do like to sit costs so far.
Very good. Very good. Not Bad,
right? I put it down after. Yeah, no,
we're talking about, you know, it's
hard. It's pretty bit lit. It's rude. No,
it was great. Yeah, it was good though.
It's good. It's good. It's very solid to,
yeah, yeah, yeah. So it's funny that
it's got that guy's fucking face brown.
Everything actually has,
if the details really,
really cool cause it has the
street in there, you don't see it.
It has the location of his drug spot in
the fucking band on this is like when
you buy these, well we're working
on right now. We'll put it together.
You know there's a big tobacco letter
they call it in in Dominican Republic who
saw the documentary.
Oh that's hilarious.
And Adam didn't know, I said, Adam, do
you have a relationship with this company?
He says, yeah. I said, well go
tell him what the fuck you are.
So he went and saw them and they
showed a documentary and they,
I think they listened to Audi's podcast
with me or something and he went,
Holy Fuck yes,
we got to Ciga for you.
So I put his face on this fucking cigar.
I think when we get mine to say
the seven five on it, doubt maybe,
you know that's not bad. So you can
even just Dowd, well doubts cigars.
Now this Guy Adam, is he stuck
in, he can't come here. Yeah,
we can call them if you want to call
them. I mean, he's dying to say hello,
but you know who really more
interesting. Oh, Walter. Well,
Walter, seem interesting.
Walt is pretty fucking cool. Can we
do that or no? You don't do this.
No need to do it now,
but listen,
this ain't the first podcast you and
aren't going to do. I'm sure we got money.
More things to talk about
it. As more things come out
and you start doing things,
I'll be happy to help you
promote on. That'd be nice. Yeah.
When the book comes out, fuck, what
do you think that's gonna. I mean,
if it's in flux right now, you
know, because the thing is,
uh, we've come to see a
couple of publishers right
now that are a little nervous.
When the fuck is wrong with
that. Listen, you pussies,
he's done the time. Shut the fuck up
so people can't get behind the ball.
I did bad things. I don't think I'm
that bad of a guy. You know what I mean?
I hope not. Anyway. I've known a lot of
bad guys. I don't think you're a bad guy.
No thank you. Did bad shit. Like I said,
I could've done that same shit. Yeah.
I think, I think people
being honest, if you're,
if you're honest about circumstantial
situations that you find yourself into and
poor decision making and being young
and doing drugs and then also being
involved in a heinous
crime riddled situation,
like your environment that
you're in, you're going to
these places, these ghettos,
you're constantly around crime. You're
constantly are on drugs. And I got,
I imagine like as you detailed in the,
in the documentary,
the crime aspect of it slowly
sort of started creeping in.
It gets you, and that was Jill.
I was young and impressionable.
You know when you see a 17 year old kid
in a Jaguar with a gooseneck fucking
equalizer, like he's the, he's the
bomb, right? And he's got, you know,
25 $30,000 in his pocket and he's got
ropes and diamonds hanging on his neck.
I'm like, what the fuck? What am I
doing here? Right? Listen, it's wrong.
Do you remember seeing that wrong?
Sometimes you remember the first piece
of crime that you did while you were a
cop? Like you never forget your
first pussy pussy like I like,
like it's an object first
woman. Excuse me. Pardon me?
People perse woman that you've had
sexual relations with. Not with that.
Who's that? Not with that. Monica.
Monica Lewinsky sex really, really did
one of these things with the thumb.
I did not as finger bent.
It's something fucker.
He had his cigars and everything
and one of these we should have.
Yeah. Well that's another story
of a rat, right? Not even her.
The other check. Doggedly won. Then
remember the whole story one? Yeah.
You just got a blonde. No, Monica Lewinsky
was friends with some old hag. Yeah,
the blonde that ratted him
out. Yeah. Yeah. It was a
blonde was a different one. Oh,
that Clem was on a
ramp. Yeah, he did good.
The last great American Dick's
Lincoln present. Yeah. Yeah.
Because now you're not allowed.
You're not allowed anymore.
We lost what it meant to be.
Do you think Schwag laughing
at these fucking idiots.
I don't want to get into that
touching. Haha. Checkmate.
He gets head and then shoots the hooker
and throws her off the top of the
Kremlin. Lao witness, he
doesn't even know. They don't,
it doesn't matter if it's a witness,
doesn't matter.
It just doesn't even have to shoot.
They got nuclear poisoning
drops for these people.
All they have all kinds of things.
But do you remember,
do you remember like the
first crime loud often?
What is, because listen, when
you, when you were a comp,
if you're not doing what you're
supposed to do by the book,
you're on the edge of
committing crime every fucking,
every time you even let somebody off
when they're supposed to be arrested,
you basically, you've committed
a crime, you know, cause you,
you've used this to discretion in an
area where there was no discretion,
you know, so, you know, so, so, but the,
but the thing I talk about is when they
took the money from the Hispanic kid,
the Puerto Rican kid, uh, in, in,
in the movie, I talk about it. Yeah.
What was that situation?
Well,
he had what we called the Puerto Rican
mystery at the time. I didn't listen.
I Love Puerto Rico's. They're my
favorite people in the word fun thing.
That's the best, you
know, they got the Remy,
they got everything going on in
the Bodegas. I loved them. They,
they helped me grow up.
I love it.
They're very flavor with me
at the same time oriented.
They love them and they
ruined me at the same time.
So what happened was this is
vet driving down and together,
when you see a vet in the ghetto, you're
going to notice it, right? I mean,
look at me. Yeah, I put it little
Ted spotless. I gotta be noticed.
But so this kid's got this vet and I
pulled him over and he's got nothing.
I mean, nothing, no license
plates, no insurance. I mean,
I'll plates on the fucking car driving it.
So,
but I noticed he had a thick wad of
hundreds in his fanny pack back then.
You know, I still wearing one or you
say back then, see that Bruce Beck,
he goes,
his dual all you got the whole thing.
I started wearing one again not too
long ago where one, I don't give a fuck.
I'm married, I'm not trying any pussy.
Yeah, you don't need to get laid for you.
I'll come, man. If I was trying to get
lit, hey girl, go get yourself a Trump.
Fuck you with a fanny pack.
Wanna fuck fucker.
That's what you and I have to dress
up for you the fuck Outta here.
Well your wife, Oh no, don't do anything.
Don't do the color headache. I get
headaches. I wouldn't want to do it.
So I pull a guy I respect. I pulled the
guy over and he goes, um, this is my,
I got nothing but he's got his benjamins
and Franklins and his fucking bay.
Right. So I just tried that he
could buy us nice lobster lunch.
Cause you know everybody eats
lobster for lunch, right? So he says,
I said, so you know, lobster lunch
kid, you know, he goes, yeah, yeah,
yeah. I said, and leave it on the back
seat. Now what you're handing me nothing.
Right, right, right. I don't want
someone to see it. First thing.
That's the first thing. So he, right.
So he leaves it a couple of
bucks on the fucking backseat.
I Dunno if it was a hundred or 200 or
there's no backseat in a corvette here.
But this was the backseat of
the police car that I had it.
Oh, I see. Yeah. Okay. So,
oh he was in the car. He was like under,
under arrest basically in the car.
And so he just takes a couple
of hundreds of his pocket,
leaves it on the fucking seat.
Okay. Okay. You have a nice day.
I don't ever want to see you again.
You hit me. That's I'm down parent.
I'm scared to death. How long had
you been on the job at this point?
Not Two years. Year and a half. Wow.
So for year and a half I
was good as a big straight
out of me. But that doesn't
really count as a year in the,
in the training you're in training and
so now in East New York and I see money.
Wow. So it's really only a
couple of months on the job.
A couple of months free. Free actually
under your own discretion back there.
Cause you gotta realize short quite a bit.
Go on in my training now.
What did you see in your trainer? Well,
I was confronted with a, under this,
this is an odd story. I was confronted
with training officers, but I,
by the time I get to train,
they had 3,600 cops graduate
the academy the same day. Okay.
Not just think about that.
That's the size of the six largest
police department in the country,
and now we hit the street like a bunch
of fucking cockroaches going everywhere.
Right. And we don't know what
the fuck we're doing. This list.
They had comp knows what he's doing
when he goes, hey kid. And he's nothing.
He has no clue. Okay. Well he knows.
It's like an accountant who
graduated county school and says,
go check this guy's books.
Oh my God.
You know what the fuck you're doing
actually doing it in practice,
how you're doing it. Right. Okay.
One of the first things happened me,
I walked out of the Madison Square Garden.
It was graduation day. My father's Dad,
I'm father retired fireman.
He's standing there with me,
but walking down the street and I'm
wearing the dress blues and sharp looking
pretty young, haven't shaved yet. And,
and uh, some woman comes walking up to me,
officer, officer, and I'm looking
like this, where's the fucking office?
I follow us. That's you. Wow. Yes ma'am.
Yes ma'am. She goes, do you know where
the Empire State building is? So I go,
I'm trying to find the
empire state building.
It's all my 34th Street in Manhattan
is the Empire State Building,
34th Street in Manhattan, Fifth Avenue.
It's two blocks straight in front of me.
Right? So I go, I'm looking around,
I go, I'm going to the standard,
go down two blocks, make a left, right.
Make a left. And so you tell people,
so my father goes, Mike is straight
ahead. I know what guy. Oh yeah,
go straight ahead up there. It's, you're
on your right and then you look up,
you see it,
you see this spire at the top of the
empire state building right there.
So anyway, that was my first day, you
know, being a cop. I didn't know I was,
I actually have one now. Right now
you're actually like, I'm one now.
I realize the magnitude is uniform. He
got on people come to you. Right? Oh Shit.
Serious. What did you see in the
[inaudible] training and training
with PSD Academy Academy?
Right. A bunch of shit.
So in training now I did six
months in the street by myself.
No one wants to cause Christa
training the other rookies.
First I was in the
second tier of training.
So now I'm learning the
street a little bit, you know,
and learn how to get a
donut. Yeah, whatever.
I got to get it done.
Not
Cause they give cops free food.
Right. Most places they did.
Legitimate establishment establishment
is, yeah, but sometimes some places do.
Some places didn't back then. And if they
do, if they didn't, you didn't go back.
So I thought everybody did. Well you
would think it's not a crime, but it is.
So you kicked her crying to fucking crime.
Why? Yeah, so that's what I'm saying.
So that's what I'm saying. Wait a
minute, wait a minute. It's a crime.
A fucking car. Free meal.
It's a crime that's wrong,
that's wrong. But it's fun. You
can give you a construction worker,
a free fucking meal. What about firemen
can give a fireman for same, same,
same thing. That's a crime, correct.
Right. Whoa. But they cook for themselves.
Nice Dick. They cook a
nice meal. And if I ask,
what should I end up going to them
quite a bit. But anyway, so, so now,
uh,
I'm committing crimes now.
W where now you were wandering
around trying to get donuts, right?
I'm getting donuts and
uh, that's it. You know,
and I'm like running
till like radio calls.
You get to see like cops running
in uniform that, you know,
it's like a little silly because you're
walking the beat because you're walking
the beat, you know, put your rookie, uh,
10 54, which is an 80 case, you know,
someone's got, you know, uh, a hernia,
whatever. In a way it location,
you don't know what the fuck it
is. You know, you start running,
you know you've full blocks later,
you see the patrol car sitting
there and they're like, kid,
you don't fucking run to
these things. That's what I
think a patrol cause for. Oh,
okay.
We just wanted to help.
We're standing on Queens Boulevard at
80 mile an hour wind blowing my skirt up
all day long. I want to see something.
You're waiting to see some action. Right.
So anyway, this goes on for six months.
So finally my first tour in the car,
I kept with these two veteran
detectives with 22 years on the job.
Each and the precinct that I was in
had just finished this scandal in the
newspaper.
It was called the one 10 sergeants club,
who my neighbor actually was involved
and he went to jail. But anyway,
so they get right to the meat of it. So
he says to me, this veteran, he goes,
you know the last guy, I don't, don't
ask me how this conversation started.
He goes, the last guy that's
connected with the scandal,
he fell over a railing on the fifth floor
during a Christmas party in the snow.
And he died. I said, oh,
what do you mean? They go,
what it does is he was rat.
He told on the cops and the one 10
precinct and he fell over the top of the
railing.
I said,
how do you fall over the top of the
fucking railing? Right? You're being,
it's a four foot ground brought I in
railing. How you go over the top of it.
Right. He just did. He
just managed to, yeah,
so he, he, I love the considered
it as suicide or accidental death,
but it was not a homicide,
so they told me that's what
happens when you turn another cup.
So I said, okay, I'm on the job
now. Little less than a year,
six months in the academy,
six months chasing people around.
They didn't know what I was doing,
eating donuts,
and now I'm being told by veteran
cops that that's what happens.
If you tell a cop that
they murdered people, well,
that things can happen. Right. Mysterious.
You can mysteriously get injured.
It doesn't seem that mysterious.
How old are you now? 48 okay.
Back then, who was pretty
mysterious then. It was just,
I was scared to ask what
happened to him. Okay, I'm good.
But I think I put the dots together.
Don't tell on a cop. Right.
So right away you're like, Oh God,
well this is, that's done this.
And within a week or two, I see him,
Robin fucking cocaine from spots.
I wasn't the same guys. Same
crew, not that same. Right.
So you're seeing, right. It wasn't,
it was, it was in corona, Elmhurst,
Jackson Heights, which is cool to
cocaine capital of New York. Actually,
the world at the time, it was more
than Miami because it was weird.
We call it a little
Columbia, was Wally, Wally,
major Colombian cartels with shipping
their cocaine to Jackson heights and
corona, and it was being shipped out
around the whole metropolitan area.
From there,
it was huge because they had the
airports then they fucking Kennedy and
Laguardia, they ran them. You know,
they ran all the fucking transportation
in and out of those locations.
So they would get jobs or get people
that would get jobs doing that pilot
baggage checked baggage handlers.
They will fucking like a free fall.
Wow. So I'm working in
this low profile precinct,
but that's what really was going
on in that. Right. And um, anyway,
what else was I gonna say?
So you're right away,
you're seeing what's going on right away.
Right away you're being indoctrinated
like almost instantaneously seeing a lot
of things that don't add up.
Right.
And now I leave there and I go
to the ghetto and I'm like, okay,
I really should've stayed in fucking
school cause this doesn't look right.
I got tears in my eyes.
I got Elvis in the ghetto playing on my,
God strike me dead.
I'm driving down Sutter Avenue.
I've just got graduated from
fucking Queens to East New York.
And that comes in the ghetto.
It was the song in the ghetto and the
young and Amala cries and I got fucking
tears in my eyes.
Oh my God,
they should have stayed in school and
you're just hating the, your choice.
You're just stuck. Scad, scared.
How long was it for you first saw your
first dead body? I had already seen that,
but because that guy actually
fell from a roof. Well,
you saw the guy and plenty
of dead bodies by that point.
Probably half a dozen at that point.
But so you actually saw the guy
who fell from the roof? No, no, no.
I saw a guy that fell from a roof
though. I know what happened. Oh yeah.
Head gets egg shaped. Um, yeah,
so he's committed suicide.
But anyway, that was my,
one of my first deal ways.
But so now you're in the ghetto and
you're there and you're scared and you're
saying I ain't got to sink or
swim. You know, it's, it's, it's,
it's time dd in the sink or you got
to swim. And I had a choice to make,
so I learned to swim quick and uh, I
was probably in the precinct, you know,
a day I saw my first murder and
then, but my dad, yeah, but I wasn't,
it wasn't my case,
so I really didn't handle it.
A couple of stabbings and then my
first midnight shift, Jesus gets shot.
Jesus gets shot. My first midnight shift.
Jesus. Hey Suze, what happened to him?
The story goes like this. I'm
working with my buddy sal. Nice guy.
He's a little older than me, the moment.
Sure. He really ready for this action.
Please. Not An active guy.
So he just wants to, he wants
to do a shift and go home.
Great. But I'm not. I'm like, I
want to be a cop on to police work.
Two guys work with a crowbar down the
street or a tire iron down the street.
It's one, one o'clock at one, two
o'clock in the morning. I'm like, Sal,
that looks a little suspicious because
it was one. I got the fucking guy.
He's got a tire iron in his hand. A little
suspicious. What do you think, Mike?
Do you really want to get involved?
I don't know.
That's what you were supposed to do.
Are the police supposed to
ask some questions? I mean,
the guy's got a tire on.
It's two in the morning.
What do you think? All right,
so I'd make a u turn go the wrong way on
Fulton Street, right by Cleveland. Uh,
one of those streets.
Cleveland, Fulton and
W. We're going back to check
up on these guys that we just,
we drove past and now we're going back
and all of a sudden we pull up in this
fucking scene in the middle of the
street guy, he's got a hole in his head.
He's laying on the ground,
obviously debt already.
And I see a tire iron sitting
right here like this, right?
But he's here in Tyrion's
over here about 15 feet away.
And I go, what happened? They
go, these two guys, I said,
the tire. And they go, yeah,
the Tyrion's right there.
It was them with the tire iron. They
ran. So they shot this kid, Jesus.
He probably went out and
confronted them and said,
what are you guys doing in
the neighborhood with a, with
a tire iron, uh, you know,
stealing because stealing cars and
tires and hubs, whatever they could get.
So he confronted them, they shot and
killed him and they took off in the wind.
So I go to sal, I go, you know what?
Nothing. Nothing. I'm glad you did.
I'm glad we didn't stop them first,
but Jesus did.
So that was my first actual shooting
that I was the, what they call it,
the first responding
officer on the scene up.
I was there about probably
a week and a half.
So I see my first murder at a week and
a half, and this is before the crack.
This is before the crack. So this is
just trade. This is straight violence,
violence, poverty. Get a home,
let's, let's just kill this guy.
Because he confronted me.
What's crazy?
The idea that the poverty in
the ghetto was already fucked.
The amazing thing was that it probably
could have been us or they would have
rent and most people try not to shoot
it out with the police right now.
Just put a right and then
I wouldn't have those.
We'll have shit to talk about
or more want it to or who knows.
Yeah.
She's amazing that the crack came along
and accelerated what was already fucked
up. Yeah. You know, I don't
know what to say. It was just,
it was amazing.
I'll tell you the one thing that was
interesting that during the correct thing,
when, when he took the cocaine from
the Panamanian government, um, in, uh,
Dionne kind of meaning army was involved
in bringing a lot of cocaine with
Noriega through the,
into our country. So w
back then it was the Kangol hats familiar
with the case, never the Cadillac. Well,
the Kangol hats,
they were getting robbed from people.
So this one kid stealing Kango,
they fucking killing each
other for the triple fat goose.
The triple fact goes tonight.
He is, and, and, and, and, and the Kangol
hats. So this kid robs has guy friends.
Kangle had someone calls nine
one one on robbery, suspect boot.
But boy he runs into a home over on,
I think it was being sick one and one
of those streets up there bite off
Atlantic Avenue and he
had a bit up on the guy.
The kid came off the subway when the kid
standing there waiting from stolen can
go at gunpoint and ran into his own home.
So we knocked on the door where the kid
lives, he won't open the fucking door.
That keeps up.
I had opened the door for you.
So he goes back upstairs and hides
the kid and it was a two family home.
The people downstairs open the door
to a common hallway cause they see the
police. They don't want to fucking
know. They didn't do nothing wrong.
They opened the door. Let me go
upstairs. Place has the shoes,
the fucking beads separate in
each room. You, you see the beads,
it's separate the rooms. Some people make
noise when it goes through the room. No,
it's sort of like, you're supposed to
know that this is two different rooms,
but they hang the beads. Oh yeah. That's
like, this is a door. But it's really not.
You know, you can see through there
pretty good. So this is how it was.
That's the given. Her
getaway is, you know,
just all the hang a curtain
to different rooms. Um,
so we get inside new seal,
the shoes and all the money that's spent
in this place, it's something's up.
So we grabbed the kid. The kid downstairs
says that's him. We can't find a gun.
So we ended up going
downstairs in the basement.
That's when you see me in
the movie talking about the
study where we found this
fucking call, the suitcase,
a wooden suitcase.
It was fucking like,
it's like two inch pie almost.
That's how thick the suitcase was wrapped
in leather. I couldn't get it open.
I'm like, I'm pretty fucking
strong guy. I couldn't get it up.
I'm trying to rip this thing open.
I don't have the combination.
There's no one standing there with
the gate. So finally one of my,
my partner comes up with a hacksaw and
I started hacks or in this fucking thing
open. What am I worried about? What about
the police? There's police all around.
This is an armed robbery suspect.
So there's a half a dozen cops Millen in
and out of the place. I killed my buddy,
watch the watch the staircase
because it was down in the basement.
Now I cut this thing open the fucking
door. When you finally get it open,
diploma fucking cocaine comes flying out
and smells like that. Bubblegum Shit.
The delicious. So I'm like,
Holy Shit, we hit pay dirt.
I'm trying to get the shootout
out and he goes, my palm, it was,
they come and they come in like who?
He goes, the owner. I go, fuck it.
Never mind the police. The owner of the
coke is coming. What do we do? Well,
we can't lock them up with steel at
his coke and now it's like the worst,
the worst position to be in. And I
find out, I'm walking out my, I'm like,
I put 50 12 pounds on, I'm trying
to get the coke out of his house.
And he's looking at me like
I stole something from him.
I feel guilty and I go,
set your stuff. He goes, no, no,
not mine. I go, okay, see you later.
So I got to patrol call, we go to
the Bodega, we wait on a fucking
scale. How much? It was like a pound
and a half, something like that.
It wasn't all that. Half of cocaine is a
lot of money, right? Well at that point,
yeah, it was. It was like we got
28,040 we have 28,000 for it,
so I bought a condo with them.
That's when I bought the condo.
At least you are investing.
That's actually smart.
Yeah, very smart. A lot of,
I mean when you said you
had four houses in a condom,
like that's actually for
a guy doing blow Robin.
I wasn't Duplo at this time
at the time just selling it,
but no one would on it. And then, yeah,
I mean you were selling it, texting.
You're technically right tech. Any
time you transfer cocaine, by the way,
if you give me a half of April right now,
you've sold it really for it.
Not just remember that now I know what
about me not, don't get me anything.
Same thing. When you transfer something,
you don't have to give money for it.
It's still considered. Wow. 20
tell us Joey d is handles it.
Hands out fucking pot candies
everywhere he goes. So you,
this was like one of the first really
big ones that you were involved with.
This is always an exciting
one to say the least.
I left there and went out and to South
Carolina, bought a condo on the ocean.
So you would kind of like,
but what happened was I went
back to the location to get more,
cause there was a lot more in there.
But when I got there,
there was a fucking limousine out front.
I swear to Christ,
there's a limousine out
front with two guys.
One stayed on each side with the
full link, trench coats on it.
I like standing there like this
and looking right at us like,
what are you going to do?
And I went, let's get the
fuck outta here. And I'm not,
this is no, this is no
yoke. I was like, okay,
I'm the police and I'm scared
to death right now. Got It.
Go Seeds is Christ and how mine did,
I ended up in the joint with Noriega.
That's all that you were in the same
place as Noriega. Did you see him? No,
he was in a, um, they give him his own
house because he's still alive. I think.
So the game is on the house? Yeah,
he had, he's like this little little,
they get in a little warehouse, a little
something going on with him, homey.
No him. There's the government have
all something going on with him.
Like give him some pussy. I
shot my hopes. No stories.
He hasn't said anything as well.
You always hope that, I mean,
or you always hear that route.
Yeah. Well this is a movie,
the witness protection program.
You get, you get pussy.
Yeah. Yeah. He wasn't in it,
but I know from guys that were,
that got kicked out of it and they get
pussy while they're in the program.
They bring him to [inaudible].
Well,
they bring in to a hotel to meet their
family. Just for you. Oh, reunion. Oh,
well that's your family though. But I
mean like Noriega. We're all family.
They got them in a warehouse somewhere.
I would imagine he's got his
own little spot and listen,
I'm not sure if you go there and
it's all fucking plush carpet.
Fucking beautiful TV. The story that
everybody drinks. Wow. You had some bid,
you know you did.
That's what everybody dreams of.
It's like that Goodfellas scenario.
It's not seen.
The movie where the cooking steaks and
slicing and dicing the goal is called
liquid base plates. Don't kid
yourself. Really? Yeah, absolutely.
And they mistake you really get steak
in joy and if you know where the right
people, oh, well what else can you get
when you're in there? Can you get girls?
Yeah. You have to pay the gods, you
know? Really? Yeah, but it's, it's rare,
but it happens. So usually it's the God
you bang and female guides Dara here,
right? That you should state. That
was that I stayed in New York.
The fenced a little more classy. You got
to send money to their private account.
Oh really? Yeah. But you can,
it all can be how anything can happen
if you have the right number. I mean,
like what's, what's the, how much you
gotta pay a guard and get some pussy?
I think the going rate was 500
but I'm not sure. 500 bucks.
He paid them 500 bucks and you can
get laid. You don't hand it to them.
You have it. Right. That seems
like it'd be worth just saying,
I'm going to double that if you have to,
certain amount of time.
It seems like a really good
deal. Really. Girls, you know,
they were out in the country,
they weren't like city girls, so,
but female guards would oftentimes
get mix it up with some person.
If I had to go back and fucking prison,
okay,
this is not a good thing for me to say
so well you're not going to go back and
just say it happened. The government
can find ways, but why would you,
why would we find we have
ways. Listen, it's not going
to happen. I know. Keep your,
keep your nose clean, keeping
those clean, you'd be fine.
But that was what happened
in upstate New York, right?
Those guys that got out when I had
the girl was supposed to wait for 10
relationship with one of them. And
it happens. It happens quite often.
It's a difficult position to be in your
a woman getting attention by men who
most of them pretty good shape,
you know, all day long like,
and I've been doing sweet
talk you and you know,
you have to fight your husband that
day and now you know you're vulnerable.
Like anything else.
I think Tupac Scott,
a song about that doesn't
mean the vulnerable when I
get free. Yeah, that's uh,
just hand you a piece of paper they're
going on. He sounds given, you know,
I don't really know if I
should talk about that.
What I made $38,000 but phone
sex in prison. Did you really?
Why would you not talk about that? He
said illegal. No, it's just I'm over it.
Wait a minute.
You make phone sex for like calling him
like gay guys would call you up? No, no,
no, no. They don't call you.
You call out and I don't have,
I didn't have a hotline in
prison now. I had a, I had a,
I had a following of
people that, you know, so
I had a woman that sent me books
on dominate trick stuff. You know,
she wanted me to dominator but master
slave books. The story of all right.
You know, if you guys, you guys
don't be too old for that, but not,
not old enough story of all was like
an incredible book about a woman.
I like to be sort of manipulated
and whatnot. And some kind
of ways. And so women,
this woman sent me, this woman sent me,
there's a bunch of books related to that,
and then I would have phone sex with
her on the phone. Of course, you know?
And she would give you money.
Yeah. I mean, wow. Yeah.
So girl pay you for phone sex.
That's pretty God damn day.
That that's pretty special. Yeah. They
call it, they call it cell phones.
I was in the sell on the phone,
but back then like that's, that's
pretty rare though, isn't it?
That like a woman would pay
a guy for that. They like,
they always say that men who are in jail
for like murder and stuff like that,
a lot of money got love. Send
them. Yeah. I had a lot of bands.
Yeah. Mostly women. People are lonely.
You [inaudible] people only, even
people in the, in the, in the free,
in the free world, that lonely, they
need tension in affection from anybody.
And you know,
it wasn't really done in a manipulative
way because I needed attention and
affection and just so happened that
she wanted me to do this right.
Right, right. I got good at it. The
gods would fight to get my Chris,
they would won't be listening because
every conversation in prisons,
I booked down the compound. They'd
be looking at me like, okay,
when are you going on tonight?
Yeah. So you would like,
like going on like it was
a performance like us now.
They couldn't wait till I got
on the phone. I don't know.
It was sweating on the other end.
I don't know.
And they were listening to
guards were listening in. Yeah.
That's fucking hilarious.
So they got mad at me.
They just make me make me
send the money home. You know,
you got too much money in your account.
You got to send it on.
The guards would make you send the money
home because you can't have too much
money in your account while
you're incarcerated because
then you could control
people in the prison. Uh, well how much
can you keep in your account? And then,
I don't know, they made I, I had
16,000 in there. They said, well,
you got to fucking sense of home and
it's saw from this one lady. Yeah.
Did you have other people who were
doing this phone sex? No, she was,
my copy was the main,
she was the Peggy.
How much did you make her prayer?
I didn't make it.
There was no salary and it wasn't, uh,
she just was sending you donations.
She had an escort business.
I didn't want to talk about this.
She had an escort business in Orlando.
She ends up getting arrested for it while
I'm on the phone with her having sex.
She gets arrested. Feel like they
broke into her house. Yeah. Oh,
y y y y. Y. So what right.
Because none of this
shit the rest of people,
but the fact is that she
ends up going to trial.
She ends up going to trial
and winning. Oh, that's a
great story for her, you know,
but my fucking donations stopped
cause she was going through hell. Wow.
That's crazy though. It was interesting.
I would say so. Yeah. I would say,
you know what, it is interesting. You
know, you have a life. We all live a life.
We all do things. And, um,
as it turns out, you know,
you can write books and
movies about everybody's life.
Everybody has listened to me right now.
Your life is way more fucked
up than most people's lives.
It was interesting,
very interesting.
But a lot of fucked up things are
interesting. But your, your story,
I mean like you saying, oh, everybody's
got an interesting, like you write a book,
but everybody like, no, no.
Listen, you wrote a book
about, you know, Jamie's life,
it'd be boring as fuck New York. He's
got a beautiful boy. He's a great guy.
Don't get me wrong. I'm just
saying no, no coke, no, no phone,
sex business, no murders. He's never
seen a dead body. I don't think. No.
See, everybody's got, you know
what I'm saying? Yeah. See you've,
you've seen some shit.
He just don't think he's seen some shit.
You know what it is. You take
things for granted, you know, short,
he lived the life I lived and even though
like I'm lucky to be alive, you know,
in many ways, um, you just,
you know, like you can,
we haven't even discussed police work
here because heroin be a bit, well,
the reason is because to me
it was a normal day. You know, I
handled 28 day jobs, average a day,
so, and then backed up on another
28. So the reality is, you know,
fucked up things I was involved in.
I mean, I don't tell you to store,
I got to tell you a story, right? You're
going to, I hope you guys enjoy this one.
This isn't entertaining. I laugh about
it myself and you know what, when I left,
don't take it the wrong way
because it's just crazy, you know,
I don't mean to demean anything or anyone.
So I'm getting ready to go to Atlanta,
to The Bahamas. And so
what I do is I do, I do,
I change my shift from, uh, from um,
from a four to 12 to a day
shift so that after the,
after the day shift I can go on my merry
vacations instead of set it ending in
four to 12 at night.
So I get a signed, uh,
a prisoner in King County Hospital and um,
she's just so many fucking
stories in my head. It just spins.
So now you realize I'm going on
vacation at the end of the shift,
I'm going to The Bahamas when it came
to the islands, I don't know someplace,
I think The Bahamas, so I don't,
I have three days growth on my face.
Now you'd get this,
is this how a cop thinks like a three
days growth on my face because I'm going
away. You can't have growth on your
face as a cop shows to be clean shaven,
mustache. But you got to be clean
shaven otherwise. So when you turn out,
you gotta look tight.
So now I'm in this hospital three days
growth on my face and I'm drunk because I
just did an all nighter because I did
a four to 12. Instead of going home,
I stayed at the precinct tap down, you
know, half a dozen or dozen, whatever.
And uh, and now I'm back at the
hospital guarding this prisoner.
I walk in the hospital and I take
the handcuffs. I switched to the kid,
wears a fucking handcuffs. He goes, he's
a rookie. He goes, what do you mean? I go,
he's a fucking prison. He's
got to be handcuffed. Well,
he wasn't handcuffed when I got here. And,
uh, I said, I take the handcuffs. I said,
I have a nice day. I put the cuffs on.
The guy didn't cuff him to his bed.
She said, what are you doing? I says, for
Christ's sakes, you're a fucking prison.
I got to sleep.
I got things to do here.
And I had a sleep catch up cause I'm
going to The Bahamas to them tonight,
tomorrow. Long Story Short, I'm
trying to shorten it. He goes,
look, I gotta take a Piss.
That's just the bathroom.
She's waking me up and I was sleeping
already. He wakes me up, so on uncuff him,
he goes to the bear of my fall back to
sleep. I thought, I bet he's in the back.
It comes back, wakes me up, I'm back
from the bathroom. I said, okay.
I got up and he goes, I just woke
you up. What? He put in the fucking,
he handcuffs on me for so I go, listen.
Anyway, he goes, I got it
now he now he wants to take
a shower, so I go, all right,
go take your fucking shower. I'm
sleeping. I said, wake me up.
When you come back and all
of a sudden about, I dunno,
10 1520 minutes later,
officer, yeah, it's a nurse.
You're a prisoner has
gone. I go, oh, no, no.
I didn't shave for three days.
I'm drunk.
I'm over and I'm going
to Bahamas tomorrow.
If you make an arrest right now,
you've got a problem because you've got
a process to the rest of all the way
through.
I got 17 overtime stood up in front of me.
I'm not making this Bahamas trip.
Oh fuck. Show I tried and
put a description over to
you haven't escaped prisoner.
Possibly escaped prisoner cause I don't
want to admit that the prisoners escaped
yet because I don't know if he is, but
he's just not here. I don't see him.
He's gone. So if, if I put over the
hair and escaped prisoner, I'm already,
I just cost myself 10 days vacation.
Okay.
That's mandatory minimum by
law and the police department,
if you lose a prisoner, you lose 10 days
vacation. Whoa. So now I'm not shaving.
All right. I can't. I'm running
around fucking kings county hospital.
I left my gun. Only I have on
is my gun. I have, you know,
cops have a jacket with your badge on
it. I took the jacket off. So all it,
all I have is a radio and a gun and
running around looking for a fucking
prisoner was cops pull up. They
see a guy with a radio. When a gun,
they don't see cop in uniform.
They don't know what the fuck I am.
I'm putting over there a
possible escape prison.
So the communication communicate,
I don't get shot,
but the communications office on the
phone goes, says, can you call me?
So I call her off with a course.
We call it central.
So I call central essentially. What's
your number? So I call it, she goes to me,
officer,
what is a possible escaped prisoner?
It's either he's escaped or he's not.
I go central.
It's not something I want to put over
the air that the fucking guy, he's gone.
I said, he may be gone. He may be
down the block, he may be sleeping.
I can't find them. She goes, okay. And
she says, what's he wearing? He says,
hospital garb. Green Hospital garb. Okay,
shoot.
She puts over the year a possible escape
prison from Kings County hospital.
We're in Green Hospital garb.
15 minutes later, seven,
five hospital posts on the air. Six,
seven sergeant. Yeah. What's up?
So yeah, we have a guy here. Can
you come meet us at the front lobby?
The king and the king's county hospital
people don't know is the size of the
fucking whole neighborhood. It's
huge. It's probably a mile this way.
A mile that way with 50 buildings in it.
And it's like a guarded fence.
But you know there's no gods
and there's no real fancy.
It's just brick walls all over the place.
So all of a sudden he comes
walking in with the guy,
the sergeant in this and a driver come
walking in with the guy and all I can do
is want to kill this
fucking guy cause I'm done.
Now the duty captain has to come down,
three captains going to
see that I haven't shaved.
And so now I'm upstairs trying to shave
and I'm bleeding now cause they give
these safety raises,
they go cut anything but you.
So I'm shaving my face with the
safety razor. I got blood all over me.
I'm trying to wipe it up
because as soon as he escaped,
it's the first thing I did
after I called for the bat,
I started shaving his beard on my
face. Or if, cause I know I'm done,
I'm getting interviewed by a duty captain,
it's going to smell the fucking booze
on my breath. And My, and my, I got,
my face is not quaffed
so I'm done because,
not because this is going to
bring attention to my drunkenness.
So I'm shaving and bleeding
incomes of sergeant,
but this fucking inmate convict
whatever he is and Perp and, um,
I look at him, he looks at me, I go,
what the fuck did you do? He goes,
there was voices telling me I had to go.
They were telling me I had to run. I go,
I pick them up. You know,
you get superhuman stinks.
I pick them up at one hand like this.
I got them against the class in Kings
County hospital and I go to him.
I want to fucking knock them out,
but the silence right there, right.
So I just go take it easy, take
it easy, take it easy. You know,
he just cost me fucking 10 days,
but I can't go on my vacation now.
So I let him down and uh,
I go
drag them back to this, his, his, uh, his
appointed bad. Now I'm going to fucking,
I want to put the cuffs around
his neck. Right? I'm like,
I know I shouldn't have fucking know.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what the voices are telling
me. I look up on his bed, it says HIV.
No.
Back then
HIV was like, you know, yeah,
you're done. I'm done. Right.
I think I got aids now touching them.
I think I got fucking aids.
So here am I just touched
your stays patient. I'm dying,
he's dying and I'm going on vacation
and I'm not, what am I gonna do now?
How do you respond to this?
So I don't know what to do.
So I'm waiting for the duty captain to
come by. I'm bleeding, I'm bleeding still.
I got holes in my face right now.
I can't even touch myself. I was,
I just touched him with my hands right
now. I got AIDS on my hands. I'm bleeding.
I'm done. I might as well just
signing my death warrant right now.
Not to mention, you know, I'm not
making this vacation because anyway,
they come to relieve me. And uh, how
the story turns out is I ended up,
I ended up on vacation in a timely manner.
I'm supposed to process the arrest.
The arrest took me about
15 minutes to process.
So I walked back into the precinct and
lieutenant on the desk goes, doubt,
you got to go back down to central booking
and processed the rest of that didn't
make that, that escaped. I don't,
I do. You're going to see that go.
I hand them a piece of paper.
Here's the arrest report to 61, uh,
the aided card and my overtime
slip. He goes, you're done.
Cause it's the guy who was trying to bang
my girlfriend. I ain't got shit done.
The guy who spotted popped in with the
red corvette. He goes, you're done. I go,
there's my, my arrest number. He
hated me. Hated each other. I go,
there's my arrest number,
there's the fucking the complaint
number and there's the aided card.
And then them overtime slip.
He knew I was going on vacation.
He called shot fucking fuming.
So ps, I lost the perp.
I got him back and I still
made the vacation. Wow.
And I ended up not losing the 10 days.
They forgot. They forgot to interview me.
They forgot their view. You. Yeah, I get,
I get end up getting interviewed about
a year later on that and they took
something from me, but it was like, yeah,
it's like it was happening. She hands.
Then they have this whole,
we have the sole thing
sitting around on our desk.
I got whatever it's over with now.
So the, the sting wasn't there and I,
I talked to lose my job.
You know, I'm drunk on duty,
losing the prison to come on.
Right. How could you not
lose your job? You got lucky.
Maybe did I definitely, I would've
lost my job. I would have safe. Right?
I don't know. I don't
know. I mean, I hate to,
everything happens for
a reason.
I fucking hate that saying sometimes
it applies scary Jesus Christ.
But you got to feel lucky that you went
through all this and you're still alive
and he's still healthy. And I
am very lucky and blessed. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, you, you've lived off, I
mean to say you've lived a colorful life.
Tired. He'd have to be Jesus Christ.
You've been running up hills. Fuck.
Just telling you these stories you carry
and awaits your whole life on Coke on
these sticks. She spindles of
Aleks, Jesus fucking Christ.
It's a crazy story and, and I'm sure you
have a million crazy stories like that.
That's, that's an easy one. That
was an easy one to tell you. No,
that's a four minute one.
Yeah. I just couldn't imagine.
I really do hope that this
does become a book. Well,
I'd like to share the stories because
they're interesting and funny, you know?
Yeah.
And you know what a lot of people like to,
not that they don't want to give the
recognition to that. This is what life is.
People live a life and you have to
share your story for people. You know,
you really do know. I like to talk
so well in the little the time.
It's like you, you were alive during
the perfect time or all this happened.
Right. The crack notice that like
you started out before the crack era,
the crack era happened while you were
in destroyed a large community of people
and people that weren't even part of the
community got destroyed because of it.
And it's think about how much would,
how much of it would be different
today because of cell phones,
because of the Internet. I
mean, it's just, you know,
we can bring it to this conversation,
that direction.
It wouldn't be the way it was,
that's for sure.
There's no way I talk about this
often. I think you really, you know,
you have to get with it. You
have to, you have to move along.
The police society has to move
along. You know, I, I listen,
I tell a story in the movie,
got a cop gets shot, right?
I ended up taking him to the hospital,
uh, and I didn't deserve to feel his pain.
And that's, that's a really hard
thing for a guy who was a cop.
I didn't deserve to feel what happened
to him and his family. And, uh,
you really, when you're a cop, you don't
want to ever feel that way. I mean,
did you feel like you were a cop did
when they were in the middle of it all?
You know what, Joe, I always felt
like a cop. I just always do.
I can come back and be a comp sci.
You always thought like,
eventually I'm going to let
this stuff called to grow up.
Just never got a chance.
I'm going to smell up,
piled up so much. You know,
you know, it's, it's Kinda,
it's a fucking crazy life man. It's really
crazy. It's not a good life, you know,
and the fact that we pay,
we're saying that, you know,
I could sit on a pile of gold or whatever,
but I love to hear that he wants to,
you know, that it's just as you turn
something bad into something good is, is,
is a good thing. But it was fucking hell.
And still, you know, I mean I'm sometimes,
I can't even go up to a comp today and
say, hey, you're doing, I'm like down.
You could do that to any cop. And they
said, Joe, nice to meet Ya. I love Ya.
I do that. I'm like, you know,
they really want to say hello to me or
what do you want to just clean it fucking
hand? You know, I had a guy
come up to me to at, at, uh,
I don't want them to previews
I did or screenings and said,
you're a fucking low life piece
of shit. Go Fuck Yourself.
It was a cop. Yeah. Yeah.
I probably couldn't squash them like a
bug, but that's not the point. You know,
and I want to show, I looked at him and
I fucking squash you. You couldn't it be,
you have to cop. I was, when I, when I
did my job. Well you couldn't be helped,
right. What it was. But you know,
the problem was like dabbled
on both sides of the same time.
That's why in the movie they said,
what were your copper? A gangster both,
you know?
Yeah.
There's that scene where the one
cop sees you coming out and he says,
he looks at you and he goes, and I don't
see cop. I see purple. Right. Well,
he's a Douche bag. They don't like
him. Why is that? No one likes him.
Internal affairs doesn't
like him. Really? Yeah.
I'm working with internal affairs right
now by the way. You're working with them?
Yeah. I didn't tell him something. No,
no, no. I'm trading them. I'm in the,
we're in the midst of finishing of a
training video for bosses comps and uh,
and, and recruits three different
videos. Wow. Well that makes sense.
That seems like something that you
would really be able to help. Yeah,
I think I could. And I,
you know, I put a little,
a lot of these films are so dry
and boring and I couldn't live.
I give it a little character
to the fucking training
session, you know, listen,
I met two beautiful women and I'm being
honest, and he told us pledge spoke,
I want to,
one was the chief of internal affairs
and one was a lieutenant and turn off is
both smoking hot. Yeah. For Real.
And they would have had me in a
minute if they just sent that man.
I would've been caught in
1987. But anyway, uh, these
two girls, uh, women and they,
uh, they fucking just, they knew,
they knew that their internal affairs
division needed something that was after
the word poignant or, or riveting.
And they said, we need you,
can you help us? It needs some character.
They need some character. Yeah.
People don't pay attention
to information for the list.
It's distributed in an entertaining way.
There's a big difference
between just flat, boring,
dry information information that's
got some, some flavor to it. And so I,
I did something with them
and, uh, I in fact, in fact,
I spoke to them last week
briefly and I told him, you know,
some of the things I was doing, they were
sort of acting jealous. I said, jealous,
you got to fucking pension.
Don't be jealous. Okay.
I'm selling my soul right now just to,
to, to, to make ends meet, you know,
and they get a pension and retirement
system, they're gonna be fine, you know,
but interesting conversation with them.
And, uh, so they are looking to, um,
to do something with that and have me
back and speak before w academy class or
you know,
I don't know about the precincts.
The guys might not open their arms to me
the way that the rookies are forced to,
you know, and then, and then I'm doing
a little some colleges right now.
I'm [inaudible] yeah, that sounds
great. A humanities classes,
some ethical classes,
uh,
for the law students and the criminal
justice departments. Uh, one of the, uh,
one of the, uh, police
departments is actually reached
out to me, um, in the south.
I don't want to put their name out
there just in case you decide not to,
but they have like 750 officers.
They want me to come.
And actually it's a great idea
and it makes a lot of sense.
I'm a very smart idea, you know, look, uh,
what I did was horrific. You know, I've
used a position to trust. I did my time.
Now I hope I can help people avoid guys
that can do what I did and it will pick
up, pick up on it. And, and
how maybe how to stop before,
like this may be guy has
the characteristics of a
guy that could go that way.
You know,
this is not an innocent happening.
This thing's just didn't happen for
because I was like greedy, which,
which is definitely part
of the reason it happened,
happened because of a bunch of political
things I will put in place back in the
80s we started promoting people based on,
based on their,
the color of their skin or their ethnicity
rather than on their promotional,
a ratings, passing tests. And
it was very, very divisive.
The police department became divided
and we all became our own actors.
And it was, it was a difficult
time for the police department.
And what you got from it was a lot of
internal strife called we hated the job,
what we love being cops.
So it was very difficult.
And the guys that love being
cops that were true to the job,
they became good cops
and got the pensions.
The guys like myself who turned into me,
they began to rebel,
come in and they're telling you
not to make arrests. You know,
they're telling you not to do this and
your boss failed three tests and you
passed. You didn't, if you
didn't pass a Meta, but you know,
so you both should be in the same ground.
Now he's your boss or she's your boss.
So it was a very,
very political upturning upheaval
within the police department itself.
When this rife time in the crack
era hit all at the same time. Yeah.
It's like a perfect storm. It was
a perfect storm. The whole thing.
It wasn't fresco and they didn't want
another fucking scandal like they had in
the 77th precinct.
Right.
Which people aren't aware of unless
they know the police department history.
Mike, we just sit three hours. Oh fuck.
That was it. That's just, that's
three hours. Just fucking listen.
We talked about the
[inaudible] dot com yes.
[inaudible] dot com and that's where
people should buy the documentary,
the seven five and Dubai, the documentary
because it is fucking five stars.
Thank you. It's outstanding. And it was
well done. It was very, very well done.
And it's, it's compelling. And, uh, so are
you, man. Thank you very much, brother.
I really appreciate it. I'm
very happy, man. You've got
to do this again. Oh, great.
Hey, look to thanks. All
right, fuckers. See soon.
Ooh,
yeah.